Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行通过Airbnb会变得更加美好。现在，你就可以通过Airbnb探索加拿大及其众多鲜为人知的本土好去处。我曾在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。在第一年的时候，剧组给我安排了一个住处。到了第二年，我说，嘿，不管那个制作预算是多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
能不能把钱给我，让我自己去找个更有人情味、更像社区的地方住，你知道吗？是的，我照做了，我租了一套Airbnb的小公寓，正对着一个公园，非常可爱。我很喜欢房东，在那里住了两个月。哇。是的，而且离杂货店很近。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的觉得在那里过上了一种精致的小生活。我在想加拿大的落基山脉地区，那里有许多湖泊和阿尔伯塔落基山脉。我不知道，总觉得如果你能在那里拥有一间温馨舒适的小木屋。你知道我的意思吗？是的。就像班夫国家公园。
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. There are very few things that you can be certain of in life. But you can always be sure the sun will rise each morning. You can bet your bottom dollar that you'll always need air to breathe and water to drink. And of course, you can rest assured that with Public Mobile's 5G subscription phone plans,
听着，也许你的下一次冒险应该考虑一下Airbnb。我是说，我们超爱它。超爱。生活中能确定的事情屈指可数。但你可以确信太阳每天都会升起。你可以百分之百确信，你永远都需要呼吸空气和饮用水。当然，你也可以放心，有了Public Mobile的5G套餐，
you'll pay the same thing every month. With all of the mysteries that life has to offer, a few certainties can really go a long way. Subscribe today for the peace of mind you've been searching for. Public Mobile. Different is calling. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
你每个月支付的费用都是一样的。在生活充满的种种未知中，有那么几件确定的小事真的能带来极大的安心。今天就订阅，寻找你一直渴望的安心感。Public Mobile。不同的声音正在召唤。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind-the-scenes details, and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hi there. We have a really special episode today. We're so excited about it.
现在，我们要为你带来专属于你的终极办公室死忠粉播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后花絮以及大量闺蜜故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妹6.0。你好。大家好。我们今天有一期非常特别的节目。我们对此感到无比兴奋。
We are going to be revisiting Boys & Girls' episode from season 2 with a very special guest. That's right. This is season 2, episode 15. Boys & Girls is very special to us for a number of reasons. First, because this episode was based on an idea that we pitched to Greg on set one day. That's right. We were standing.
我们将与一位非常特别的嘉宾一起重温第二季的《男女有别》这一集。没错。这是第二季第15集。《男女有别》对我们来说有着特殊的意义，原因有很多。首先，因为这一集是基于我们有一天在片场向格雷格提出过的一个构想。没错。当时我们正站着。
I remember by the copier that was between reception and accounting and we were chit chatting. And we were like, Greg, Greg, we have an idea for an episode. And he walked over and we both said, look, we tipped in corporate America and we would have to go to these like women seminars. Women in the workplace seminars. And so we said, wouldn't it be funny if Jan came in and threw a women in the workplace seminar and Michael got all jealous and he threw a men in the workplace
我记得就在前台和会计部之间的复印机旁，我们在闲聊。然后我们说，格雷格，格雷格，我们对一集节目有个构想。他走了过来，我们俩就说，你看，我们在企业界混过，经常得去参加那种女性研讨会。职场女性研讨会。所以我们就说，如果简进来开一个职场女性研讨会，而迈克尔嫉妒得要死，然后他也搞了一个职场男性研讨会，
seminar. And Greg was like, oh my gosh, I love it. Wait, wait, BJ, come here. Yeah. BJ was sitting over by Creed and he was like, get over here, grab a notepad. And literally he was like, jot this down. And he was like, tell him what you just told me. So we told BJ, same thing, and then Greg goes, then what happens? And we were like, no idea. We don't know, that's all we got. But BJ was like, okay, okay.
这不是很搞笑吗？格雷格听了就说，哦天哪，我太喜欢了。等等，等等，BJ，过来。是的。BJ当时坐在克里德旁边，格雷格就说，过来，拿个记事本。他真的是原话照搬，说，把这个记下来。然后他说，把刚才对我说的话告诉他。于是我们把同样的话告诉了BJ，接着格雷格问，然后呢？我们当时就说，不知道。我们不知道，我们就这点存货。但BJ却说，好吧，好吧。
And he would ask us some questions, and I think there were like a number of things that kind of made their way into the episode that were based on some of the questions that BJ asked us. And then he got assigned to write it. Boys and girls. Yes, so fun. Well, it was also really special to us
然后他问了我们一些问题，我觉得最终有不少内容都被融进了这一集里，都是基于BJ问我们的那些问题。接着他就被指派去写剧本了。男女有别。是的，太有趣了。嗯，这一集对我们来说也真的非常特别，
because it was directed by Denny Gordon, who at the time in 2006 was only the second woman to direct an episode of The Office. And she joined us in the studio to talk about her time on the show. This was such a wonderful interview. Oh, my goodness. From the minute she walked in the door, you'll hear.
因为它是由丹妮·戈登执导的。在2006年那个时候，她还是《办公室》仅有的第二位女性导演。她来到我们的工作室，和我们聊了聊她在剧组的日子。这是一次非常棒的访谈。哦，天哪。从她走进门的那一刻起，你们就会听出来的。
Yes. And you'll get it. She's just amazing. She just walked in the door and hugged us and told us how proud she was of us. I know. We were like trying not to tear up because we respect her so much. Yeah. We actually wrote about Denny Gordon in our book, The Office BFFs. We did a little research for the book and we found that of the 55 different directors
是的。而且你们会懂的。她简直太棒了。她一进门就拥抱了我们，告诉我们她为我们感到多骄傲。我懂。我们当时都快要感动得落泪了，因为我们太尊敬她了。是的。我们其实在我们的书《办公室闺蜜》中写到过丹妮·戈登。我们为这本书做了一些研究，发现《办公室》的55位不同导演中，
that we had on The Office, only six were women. Denny directed two episodes of The Office, actually. She directed The Secret and Boys and Girls. She is such a trailblazer among female directors in film and television. She was one of the first women to graduate from the Yale School of Drama with an MFA in directing. She has directed over 100 hours of network television
只有6位是女性。其实丹妮执导了《办公室》的两集。她执导了《秘密》和《男女有别》。她是影视界女性导演中的先锋人物。她是第一批从耶鲁戏剧学院获得导演专业MFA（艺术硕士）学位的女性之一。她执导过超过100小时的网络电视节目，
as well as films and commercials. She has a very long and impressive resume. And she's also directed several episodes of John Krasinski's show, Jack Ryan. Yeah, and we talked to her about that too. We did. We also shared a photo in our book that we took during the filming of Boys and Girls. It's really special to us.
还导演过电影和商业广告。她的履历非常长且令人印象深刻。她还执导过好几集约翰·卡拉辛斯基的剧集《杰克·莱恩》。是的，我们跟她也聊了这件事。没错。我们在书中还分享了一张照片，是我们拍摄《男女有别》时拍的。对我们来说真的非常特别。
We were basically on set one day and we looked around and realized it was just us gals that were working the whole day. So we all gathered around Denny for a picture. It's so great. You have to share it in stories, Ange. I will. We're also going to discuss the extra footage added
我们有一天在片场，环顾四周突然发现，那一整天工作的全都是我们这些女将。于是我们所有人聚在丹妮周围拍了张照片。太棒了。安吉，你得在动态里分享一下。我会的。我们还将讨论为《男女有别》的超级粉丝版
to the super fan version of Boys and Girls. So the original broadcast ran at 21 minutes and 21 seconds, and the extended cut has an additional 10 minutes and 84 seconds. So that's a lot of extra scenes. Well, when we talked to Dave Rogers about creating the superfan episodes, he said Boys and Girls was one of his favorites. He gave us his list of top 10 super fan episodes and this is one of them.
增加的额外片段。原版播出的时长是21分21秒，而加长剪辑版额外增加了10分84秒。所以有非常多的额外场景。嗯，当我们跟戴夫·罗杰斯聊到制作超级粉丝版剧集时，他说《男女有别》是他的最爱之一。他把他的超级粉丝版TOP 10剧集列了给我们，这一集就是其中之一。
I loved watching it. I mean, I can see why he said that. So many of the scenes are extended. And also not only are they extended, but they really add to the story. Yes, exactly. I think really enrich the story. That's right.
我特别喜欢看。我是说，我能理解他为什么这么说。很多场景都被加长了。而且不仅加长了，它们还真正为故事增色不少。是的，完全如此。我认为真的让故事更加丰富了。没错。
Well, before we go to break, let me give a quick summary of the episode. But rather than have me summarize the episode, let's hear what Pam has to say. Today's a women in the workplace thing. Jan's coming in from corporate to talk to all the women about, um, I don't really know what, but Michael's not allowed in. She said that about five times. And then of course, Michael has his version of what's happening. Let's hear that.
好了，在进入广告休息之前，让我对这一集做一个简短的总结。不过与其由我来总结这一集，不如听听帕姆怎么说。今天有个职场女性的主题活动。简从总公司过来，要跟所有女性谈谈……嗯，我其实不知道谈什么，但迈克尔不准参加。她这话大概说了五遍。然后当然了，迈克尔也有他对正在发生的事情的看法。我们来听听看。
Yeah, translation. I have been banned from my own conference room so that Jan can talk in secret to all the girls. Whoa, sorry, Women of the workplace. About what? I don't know. Clothes. Me. Ugh. He's so put out that they're talking about me.
是的，翻译一下。我已经被禁止进入我自己的会议室了，这样简就能跟所有女孩私下谈话。哇，不好意思，是职场女性。谈什么？我不知道。衣服。我。呃。他对她们在谈论我这件事感到超级不爽。
I know. Probably him. Yeah. Well, Michael gets upset when he's excluded from the seminar, so of course he's going to have his own meeting with all of the men down in the warehouse. And meanwhile in this episode, this is the one where Jan tells Pam about a special design program that the company is offering.
我知道。可能就是在说他。是的。嗯，迈克尔因为被排挤在研讨会之外而很不高兴，所以他理所当然地要和仓库里所有的男员工开他自己的会。与此同时在本集中，这也是简告诉帕姆关于公司提供的一个特殊设计项目的那一集。
Jim is encouraging her to do it, Roy is not, and ultimately Pam decides not to pursue it. Very dramatic arc in this one. Very dramatic. That Pam talking head kind of in this one. Very dramatic. That Pam talking head kind of breaks my heart. I know. Well, the super fan episode starts
吉姆鼓励她去申请，罗伊则不同意，最终帕姆决定放弃。这一集的剧情冲突非常戏剧化。非常戏剧化。帕姆的那个单人访谈在这一集里简直……有点让我心碎。我知道。嗯，超级粉丝版的开头
with a whole new cold open. And lady, I loved it because it's more of Michael versus technology. Yes, it's very funny. Well, it starts with Michael hanging out at front reception. Yeah, he tells Pam that he's really overwhelmed because he just spent $400 on a new phone because he liked the ringtone,
是一个全新冷开场。天哪，我太喜欢了，因为这又是迈克尔与科技的较量。是的，非常搞笑。嗯，开场是迈克尔在前台闲晃。是的，他告诉帕姆他快崩溃了，因为他花400美元买了一部新手机，只因为他喜欢那个铃声，
only to learn that you can choose any ringtone you want. He thought the ringtone came specifically with the phone. But also, lady, he has a flip phone. He spent $400 on a flip phone? I don't know. Did they ever cost that? I wanted to look it up, but I didn't. And then Michael's like going through
结果却得知你可以选择任何你想要的铃声。他以为那个铃声是手机自带的。而且，天哪，他用的是一部翻盖手机。他花400美元买了一部翻盖手机？我不知道。它们以前卖过这个价吗？我想查一下，但没查。然后迈克尔开始翻看
all the different ringtones. Some are like classical, but the one that he really loves makes the sound kind of like a jackhammer and he makes the noise. It's like, grr, grr, grr. And Jim goes, do you mean vibrate? Because they all have vibrate.
各种不同的铃声。有些听起来像古典音乐，但他真正超爱的那一个发出的声音听起来有点像凿岩机，他还模仿了那个声音。听起来就像，格——格——格——。然后吉姆说，你是说震动吗？因为它们都有震动功能。
They all have that. Little bit of old tech made me chuckle. Well, listen, why don't we go to break and when we come back, you're going to hear our conversation about this Peacock Extended episode of Boys and Girls with Director Denny Gordon. It is not to be missed. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I just had a visit with my mom and I was kind of thinking about all the ways that she has
它们都有那个功能。这种老式科技的小细节让我忍不住笑出来。好了，听着，我们为什么不去休息一下，等我们回来，你们将会听到我们关于派拉蒙（注：此处指Peacock，直译或误听为Peacock）加长版《男女有别》与导演丹妮·戈登的对话。千万不要错过。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。我刚刚去看望了我妈妈，我一直在脑海中回想她是如何
really informed my life as an adult. And one of the things that I really admire about her is that she was always willing to ask for help when she needed it. For advocating for herself. Yeah. Well, you know, mental health awareness is growing now, but there's still progress to be made. 26% of Americans who participated in a recent survey say they have avoided seeking mental
在各个方面塑造了我作为一个成年人的人生。我非常崇拜她的一点是，她在需要帮助时总是愿意主动寻求帮助。为自己发声。是的。你知道，现在人们对心理健康的意识在不断提高，但仍有进步的空间。在最近的一项调查中，有26%的受访美国人表示，他们因为害怕遭受评判而避免寻求心理
health support due to fear of judgment. Well this Mental Health Awareness Month, let's encourage everyone to take care of their well-being and break the stigma. BetterHelp is fully online. It's making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. And you can easily switch therapists anytime at no cost. We're all better with help. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help, help.com slash office ladies. Hey, it's Morgan Absher.
健康支持。在这个心理健康意识月，让我们鼓励每个人都关爱自己的身心健康，打破偏见。BetterHelp完全在网上进行。它让治疗变得负担得起且便捷，已为全球超过500万人提供服务。而且你可以随时免费更换治疗师。有帮助，我们会更好。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠office ladies，享受你第一个月的九折优惠。网址是betterhelp点com斜杠office ladies。嗨，我是摩根·阿布舍尔。
And I'm Kaylen Moore. And we're the hosts of the Crime House original podcast, Clues. Every Wednesday, we sneak past the crime scene tape and open a new case file for some of the most gripping true crime cases. While Kaylen pieces together the timelines and breaks down the hard facts of these cases, I'llin pieces together the timelines and breaks down the hard
我是凯伦·摩尔。我们是Crime House原创播客《线索》的主持人。每周三，我们都会潜入犯罪现场警戒线后，为一些最扣人心弦的真实犯罪案件打开新的卷宗。当凯伦拼凑时间线并剖析这些案件的确凿事实时，
facts of these cases, I'll be diving into the theories and pulling at the threads that may or may not add up. From serial killers to shocking murders, clues dives into all the forensic details and brilliant sleuthing that went into the world's most infamous cases. These clues shine a light on stories that have been waiting, sometimes for decades, to finally be heard. So join us as we open a case and uncover the breakthroughs, the heartbreak, and the relentless pursuit of answers behind these unforgettable investigations. Follow and Listen to Clues, an Odyssey podcast and partnership with Crime House, available now on the free Odyssey app and wherever you get your podcasts.
我会深入研究各种理论，抽丝剥茧那些可能说得通或说不通的线索。从连环杀手到令人震惊的谋杀案，《线索》深入探讨了世界上最臭名昭著的案件背后的所有法证细节和精彩侦查过程。这些线索照亮了那些等待了有时长达数十年、终于得以重见天日的故事。所以，加入我们，一起开启一个案件，揭开这些难忘调查背后的突破、心碎与对答案的不懈追寻。关注并收听《线索》，这是一档由Odyssey播客与Crime House合作推出的节目，现已在免费的Odyssey应用程序以及各大播客平台上线。
Hi there, I'm Ryan Reynolds and I have a list of things I like to have on set. It's just little things like two freshly cracked eggs, scrambled with crispy hash browns, sausage, crumble, and creamy Chipotle sauce from Tim Hortons. From my writer to Tim's menu, try my new scrambled eggs loaded breakfast box. Denny, hello and welcome to the studio. I am super excited to be here.
嗨，我是瑞安·雷诺兹，我有一份我在片场喜欢吃的食物清单。这只是一些小东西，比如两个新鲜打碎、炒得酥脆的薯饼、香肠碎，以及蒂姆荷顿（Tim Hortons）的浓郁奇波雷酱炒蛋。从我的编剧到蒂姆的菜单，快来尝尝我全新的炒蛋至尊早餐盒吧。丹妮，你好，欢迎来到工作室。我超级兴奋能来到这里。
I've been fans of your show and thank you for having me. I mean, it took me back to look at all the old episodes and what a blast, how deliciously fun. Normally I can't go back and look at episodes and this was just beyond fun, so thank you. Oh, wow. Well, we have been wanting to talk to you for a long time. So you really just made our dreams come true by being here today. So thank you. Oh, wow. Well, we have been wanting to talk to you for a long time.
我是你们节目的粉丝，谢谢你们邀请我。我是说，重新看以前的那些老剧集让我梦回当年，简直太棒了，太有趣了。通常我没法回看以前的剧集，但这次简直好玩到爆，所以谢谢你们。哦，哇。嗯，我们一直很想跟你聊聊。所以你今天能来到这里，真的让我们梦想成真了。所以谢谢你。哦，哇。嗯，我们一直很想跟你聊聊。
So you really just made our dreams come true by being here today. Bless you. Bless you. Now, you directed two episodes of The Office. You directed The Secret and Boys and Girls. We always ask people this question, how did you get your job directing The Office? Well, I had done a couple of shows with our beloved Ken Guavis, and we knew each other.
所以你今天能来到这里，真的让我们梦想成真了。保佑你。保佑你。现在，你执导了《办公室》的两集。你执导了《秘密》和《男女有别》。我们总是问大家这个问题，你是怎么得到《办公室》导演这份工作的？嗯，我跟我们挚爱的肯·瓦皮斯合作过好几部剧，我们互相认识。
And I think he started talking to Greg Daniels about me. And I think Greg and I had the same agent. So I think Richard White's super agent was, you know, blah, blah, and about me. So I got an interview. And of course, you were the hottest show on the planet at the time, I mean, and continued to be so, like, I was so thrilled. I thought, even if I don't get a job, I mean, and continued to be so like, I was so thrilled.
我想他开始跟格雷格·丹尼尔斯聊起我。而且我觉得我和格雷格用的是同一个经纪人。所以理查德·怀特的超级经纪人大概就在那儿“叭叭叭”地向他推荐我。于是我得到了一个面试机会。当然，你们当时可是地球上最火的剧集，我是说，现在依然如此，我当时简直激动坏了。我想，哪怕我没得到这份工作，我是说，现在依然如此，我当时简直激动坏了。
I thought even if I don't get a job, I'm just so excited to be in the mix and have a chance to talk. And I met Greg at the Earth Cafe. And what was crazy was it was not even an interview. It was like, Greg just started downloading to me all these wonderful idiosyncrasies about the show, you know, how you shot it and your process and how you created this environment and how special it was and just all these tips on how I might come live in that world with you for a while. So when I got a chance to come over, I thought I'd died and gone to heaven.
我想，哪怕我没得到这份工作，能加入其中并有机会聊聊，我就已经兴奋得不行了。我在Earth咖啡馆见到了格雷格。疯狂的是，这甚至都不像是一场面试。那感觉就像是，格雷格开始向我倾囊倒出关于这部剧的所有奇妙特质，你知道的，你们是怎么拍摄的、你们的流程、你们是如何创造出这种环境的、它是多么特别，以及关于我如何能和你们一起在这个世界里生活一段时间的各种小建议。所以当我有机会加入时，我觉得自己就像是死后上了天堂。
Wow, that's so great. So we've asked a lot of people about their first meeting with Greg and they've said that a lot of people about their first meeting with Greg, and they've said that a lot of times conversation went to all kinds of places and lasted like an hour, and it sounds like you guys had a great first meeting. It was a great first meeting. He dropped so much knowledge on me, so many things I still remember to this day and think of in all the work that I'm doing. One of the things he said was
哇，太棒了。所以我们问过很多人关于他们第一次见格雷格的经历，他们说很多人关于他们第一次见格雷格的经历，并且他们说很多时候对话会延伸到各种各样的地方，持续大约一个小时，听起来你们第一次见面聊得很愉快。这是一次非常棒的初次见面。他向我灌输了太多的知识，有那么多事情我至今仍记忆犹新，并在我所做的所有工作中不断思考。其中他提到的一点是
of in all the work that I'm doing. One of the things he said was how important it was to just remember we were a documentary. And it had never dawned on me, even though I'd been devoted to your show and watching, was that sometimes we would rehearse something and then there'd be a swish pan to rain or something. And how that always had to stay spontaneous and how you had to keep the camera late in getting there because you don't know that magical moment is going to happen. So it really required a very lively camera and of course Randall was awesome and the operating was so key and it was just so of the moment and when Greg started talking about
在我所做的所有工作中不断思考。他提到的一点是，记住我们是一部纪录片是多么重要。我以前从来没有意识到这一点，尽管我一直非常喜欢你们的剧并且经常观看，但有时我们会排练某些东西，然后镜头会突然摇向雨景或其他什么。那个镜头必须始终保持即兴感，而且你必须让摄像机慢一步到达，因为你不知道那个神奇的时刻什么时候会发生。所以这确实需要一个非常生动的镜头，当然兰德尔太棒了，运镜也至关重要，一切都是当下的真实反应。当格雷格开始谈论
that and how we keep that so that it feels like we're capturing life, which was so critical on this show. When he started talking about that, it was just so amazing. Yeah, I think our conversation spun around a lot of ways, but he did really get me so excited and intrigued because I began to see how you worked and the process, you know, there's this secret little world and we close the door and all the crew is gone and there we are and you're powdering your own nose and you're journaling at your desk
这一点，以及我们如何保持这种状态以使其感觉我们正在捕捉生活（这在这部剧里至关重要）。当他开始谈论这些时，简直太惊人了。是的，我觉得我们的谈话有很多不同的走向，但他确实让我感到非常兴奋和着迷，因为我开始看出你们是如何工作的以及其中的流程，你知道的，这里有一个秘密的小世界，我们关上门，所有的工作人员都离开了，我们就待在那里，你自己在扑粉，你在桌子写日记，
and everybody is just, you know, you remember, everybody's just behaving and it was such a magical time and place, I've never experienced that anywhere before. So it was such a magical time and place. I've never experienced that anywhere before. So it was such a gift. Oh, my God. How did you prep for directing the show? Well, crazily enough, I had been making a film in the UK. So I had watched the UK version. I was out of my mind over it. I remember saying to somebody, a producer,
每个人都只是，你知道的，你还记得，每个人都在安分守己，那真是一个神奇的时间和地点，我在其他任何地方都没有经历过。所以那真是一个神奇的时间和地点。我在其他任何地方都没有经历过。所以这真是一份厚礼。天哪。你是如何为执导这部剧做准备的？嗯，疯狂的是，我当时正在英国拍一部电影。所以我看过英国原版。我当时对它简直着迷到发疯。我记得曾对某个制片人说，
we should buy the rights. Of course, you guys, I think, were already in production. But I watched, of my mind over it. I remember saying to somebody, a producer, we should buy the rights. Of course, you guys I think were already in production. But I watched, of course, all of season one. And I think it was such a well-oiled machine, you guys. I mean, I think I had the script well before I came. And I think I came over a couple days to observe. I don't know, maybe Ken was directing and I got a chance to observe. Because it was so unusual.
我们应该买下版权。当然，你们当时大概已经在制作中了。但我看过了，着迷到发疯。我记得曾对某个制片人说，我们应该买下版权。当然，你们当时大概已经在制作中了。但我看过了第一季的所有内容。我觉得你们已经是一个运作良好的机器了。我是说，我想我在来之前很久就拿到剧本了。我想我提前几天过来观摩。我不知道，也许当时是肯在执导，我有机会去观摩。因为这太不寻常了。
It was pretty rare air and how you guys worked and how you achieved what you were achieving really needed to be a good fit. So I was super keen to fit in and fall in line. Of course, Ken Kwapa is the hardest act to follow on the planet as a director. He's like, oh my God, we're not worthy. And I remember thinking, with this group of superstars, I don't need to be doing your homework for you.
这是一种相当罕见的氛围，你们的工作方式以及你们所取得的成就确实需要高度契合。所以我非常渴望融入并服从大局。当然，作为一名导演，肯·瓦皮斯是地球上最难超越的榜样。他就像是，哦天哪，我们不配。我还记得当时想，面对这群超级巨星，我不需要替你们做家庭作业。
You will do your homework for you. You know these people so well that, man, I'm just lucky if I can come in and maybe figure out what's the most fun place to play this scene? Where's the chance for physical comedy? That's how I can help. But that you guys knew yourselves so well that it was just how do I keep that atmosphere going
你们会自己做家庭作业的。你们对这群人如此了解，天哪，如果我能介入并弄清楚在哪里以最有趣的方式演绎这个场面？哪里有机会展现肢体喜剧？那我能帮上忙就已经很幸运了。而你们对自己如此了解，所以问题只在于我如何维持这种氛围，
so you can live and breathe in this moment? Yeah. You certainly put the camera, I thought, in some really fantastic places. And if you watch the Superfan episodes, there are a few tags and things. There's a shot of Madge in the warehouse pushing her cart, and the camera is really low on the ground, so you're kind of looking up her neck and up her nose a little bit. And she's just pissed off at just being a part of it.
好让你们在这个瞬间鲜活地呼吸？是的。我当时觉得，你确实把镜头放在了一些非常奇妙的位置。如果你看超级粉丝版，会有一些小标签之类的东西。有一个镜头是马奇在仓库里推着推车，镜头压得很低，所以你有点像是在抬头看着她的脖子和一点点鼻子。她只是对卷入其中感到很不爽。
But it just built that moment so wonderfully. Oh, thank you. I know that. I'd forgotten about so much of that. at just being a part of it, but it just built that moment so wonderfully. Oh, thank you. I know that. I'd forgotten about so much of that. That's what was so delicious about these extended episodes. These super fan episodes are crazy. Great. Aren't they amazing? Yes. Yes.
但这个镜头把那个时刻烘托得太美妙了。哦，谢谢。我知道。我都快把那些忘光了。对卷入其中感到很不爽，但这个镜头把那个时刻烘托得太美妙了。哦，谢谢。我知道。我都快把那些忘光了。这些加长版最美妙的地方就在于此。这些超级粉丝版简直棒呆了。不觉得太棒了吗？是的。是的。
It's so... There was, especially this episode, there was so much extra. It was able to breathe. In fact, let's jump in because this episode opens and Jan has gathered all the women in the conference room. She's going to start her Women in the Workplace seminar. But Michael, of course, is super jealous and annoyed that he's not included. So he keeps busting in.
太……尤其是这一集，有太多的额外内容了。它有了呼吸的空间。事实上，让我们直接切入正题，因为这一集的开场是简把所有的女性都召集到了会议室。她要开始她的职场女性研讨会了。但迈克尔当然超级嫉妒，对没有邀请他感到恼火。所以他一直闯进来。
Jan eventually throws him out. The superfan episode is so great because it just includes more stuff from Jan. She talks about how men who are assertive are respected, but women who are assertive get called the B word or the C word. And it just kind of builds even more on the premise, which I really loved. And we were curious, what were your thoughts
简最后把他赶了出去。超级粉丝版太棒了，因为它包含了更多简的桥段。她谈到了自信的男性会受到尊重，而自信的女性却被称为“B开头”或“C开头的词”。这让这个前提更加饱满，我真的非常喜欢。我们很好奇，当你第一次读到这个剧本时，
when you first read this script? Like, did this speak to you in any way? It definitely spoke to me. It totally spoke to me. You know, at this point in my career, I think I had been everywhere I'd gone to direct. I was usually the only woman in the whole season. So it's like I really, you know, was relating. It's so much better now. And we've still got miles to go, but at the time I was always the lonely chick and I remember thinking how great the script was that BJ Novak wrote and that we were going to get to see all of you guys reacting to this idea, you know, pre-human resources, pre-canceling, like women in the workplace, boys and girls, you know,
你的想法是什么？这个剧本在某种程度上触动了你吗？它绝对触动了我。它完全触动了我。你知道，在我职业生涯的这个阶段，我觉得我去过的每一个导演过的地方，我通常都是整个剧组里唯一的女性。所以这就像我真的，你知道的，感同身受。现在情况好多了。我们还有很长的路要走，但在当时我总是那个孤独的女孩，我记得当时觉得BJ·诺瓦克写的剧本太棒了，我们将看到你们所有人对这个想法的反应，你知道的，在人力资源普及之前，在“取消文化”之前，就像职场女性、男女有别，你知道的，
what do people really think of these issues? And it was, I just thought, if I do it right, we're gonna have like all these wonderful surprises about your characters and how you really feel about things. It was a goldmine, I knew, you know, BJ had just like, it was the tip of the iceberg and there was always gonna be so much extra, I mean, I remember we were 10 minutes over
人们对这些问题到底是怎么想的？我当时就想，如果我处理得当，我们就会对你们的角色以及你们对事物的真实感受产生所有这些美妙的惊喜。我当时就知道这是一个金矿，你知道的，BJ只是展现了冰山一角，而且总会有那么多的额外内容，我是说，我记得我们超时了10分钟
in the extra super version, we had 10 minutes of gold that the audience didn't get to see. Yeah. Yeah. So glad for that because jokes didn't even have time to pay off. Yeah. You know, in lots of ways, like the fact that the guys had unloaded that Michael had told them to unload the truck. And we thought, okay, well, that goes. But then we realized that that was a shipment going out. Out.
在超长版本中，我们有10分钟的精彩片段是观众在正片里没看到的。是的。是的。为此感到庆幸，因为有些笑话甚至都没有时间铺垫出效果。是的。你知道，在很多方面，比如男人们已经卸下了——迈克尔告诉他们去卸货。我们想，好吧，那段删掉。但后来我们意识到那是一批要发货的货物。出货。
Yeah. Okay, well that goes, but then we realized that that was a shipment going out. Out, yeah. So we really needed that time to let it breathe. So thank God for the super episodes. I wanted to talk about a scene that's extended in the super fan that I thought really built with that extra footage. So, you know, Michael has come into the conference room and he's interrupted this women's meeting
是的。好吧，那段删掉，但后来我们意识到那是一批要发货的货物。出货，是的。所以我们真的需要那段空间让它呼吸。所以感谢超级粉丝版。我想聊聊一个在超级粉丝版中被加长的场景，我觉得那个额外的片段真的很加分。所以，你知道，迈克尔走进了会议室，打断了这个女性会议，
and Jan throws him out and he just can't take it. He can't take it that the ladies have this meeting, so he gathers the guys in the bullpen. Of course, he sits right up against that conference room window. He even bangs it and they're so loud. The way you cut the scene back and forth in the extended version, you can actually hear how inappropriate Michael's being because you actually go into the conference room, whereas in the
简把他赶了出去，而他简直无法接受。他无法接受女士们开这个会，所以他在办公区把男人们召集起来。当然，他就坐在紧挨着会议室玻璃窗的地方。他甚至还拍打玻璃，他们声音太大了。在加长版中你剪辑这个场景的方式，让你实际上能听到迈克尔有多么不合适，因为你真的走进了会议室，而在
original way it's edited they're outside the whole time, and I thought Denny we should hear it. Yes. Oh God, what fun. My favorite. Yeah, he's really banging against that glass. Yeah. So to be in a position of leadership, you often need to be assertive, right? You have to be able to state a firm opinion. And this means that you have to give up the fantasy of being everyone's friend. Well first of all, I just want to warm up a little bit. Now I know this is going to sound crazy to you, but in India they do this thing called
原版的剪辑方式中，他们全程都在外面，我觉得丹妮，我们应该听听看。是的。哦天哪，太好玩了。我的最爱。是的，他真的在拍打那块玻璃。所以，要处于领导地位，你往往需要表现得自信，对吧？你必须能够表达坚定的观点。这意味着你必须放弃成为每个人朋友的幻想。好吧，首先，我想先热身一下。现在我知道这听起来对你很疯狂，但在印度他们有一种东西叫做
laughter therapy. And I want to try it out. It's when a group of people just get together and they laugh as hard as they can. So I want to try that with you right now on the count of three. Let's laugh as hard and loudly as we can. Ready? One, two, three. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Oh my God, I love that so much. And what was so great, when I think we discovered this in rehearsal, was what's Jan gonna do? And she goes back in and closes the blind so that they're not even there. There was another physical comedy moment I think we discovered,
大笑疗法。我想尝试一下。就是一群人聚在一起，尽可能大声地笑。所以现在我想在数到三的时候和大家一起试试。让我们尽可能大声、尽情地笑出来。准备好了吗？一，二，三。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈garrrr！天哪，我太喜欢这个了。而且最棒的是，我觉得我们在排练时发现了这一点，那就是简会怎么做？她走回去把百叶窗拉上，这样他们甚至都看不见外面了。这是我们发现的另一个肢体喜剧时刻，
but yeah, that teed up everything that's gonna follow. That's right. And I loved it so much. God, there was just so much there. And what a poignant episode. I remember, you know, and going around the room and hearing from everybody on your side and every, you know, you all had such interesting reactions.
但没错，这为接下来要发生的一切做好了铺垫。确实如此。我太喜欢了。天哪，里面有太多内容了。而且这是一集多么感人的剧集。我记得，你知道，环顾房间，听取你们那边每个人的想法，你知道，你们所有人都产生了如此有趣的反应。
I think you said you were in the most mature relationship of your adult life. And then we cut to you and Rain being super awkward going through a door. I know. You know, and then the reveal of your interest in art and that you actually started a beautiful drawing. Yes. Yes.
我想你说你正处于成年生活中最成熟的恋爱关系中。然后镜头切到你和雷恩（Rain）非常尴尬地通过一扇门。我懂。你知道的，然后揭晓了你对艺术的兴趣，以及你实际上开始了一幅精美的画作。是的。是的。
Tell me about that. Did you just make that up on, was that in the script or did you just do that? That was Phil Shea, the prop master, gave me that notebook with that sketch in various forms of being done because I couldn't draw something like that. And so that was like his contribution
跟我讲讲那个。你是即兴发挥的，那是剧本里的，还是你本来就会画？那是菲尔·谢（Phil Shea），道具师，他把那个记事本交给我，上面有那个素描的不同完成阶段，因为我自己画不出那样的东西。所以那是他的贡献，
that I be like kind of doing that sketch. And I know, I noticed that too. I thought, what a great detail, right? Such a fantastic detail. And you know, the other, the thing that is so incredible that, you know, in our life, we're maybe blessed to have a, be on a show where everyone cares so much about what we're doing that our prop man
让我看起来像是在画那幅素描。我知道，我也注意到了。我想，多棒的细节啊，对吧？真是个绝妙的细节。你知道，另一个令人难以置信的事情是，你知道，在我们的生活中，我们可能很幸运能参演这样一部剧，每个人都如此关心我们在做的事情，以至于我们的道具师
would be so deeply involved in the story that he would think that for you and offer that up to you. I mean, that was part of the magic of the thing. Every single person in that family was rooting for the best show possible. I mean, that's just one example. That's truly how it felt, though. Like, we're only as good as our weakest person or, you know,
会如此深切地投入到故事中，他会为你着想并向你提供这个。我的意思是，这就是整部剧魔力的一部分。那个大家庭里的每一个人都在为呈现最棒的剧集而加油。我的意思是，这只是一个例子。不过，这确实是当时的真实感受。就像，我们只有在最弱的环节上才表现得一样好，或者说，
like everyone was a collective. And, and Denny, you just came right in to the fold, just like that. Like, I felt like you elevated us. And Jen and I've talked about this on the podcast, just we had this moment where we all looked around and we're like, it's only us gals. There's only gals on the set today.
就像每个人都是一个集体。而且，丹妮（Denny），你一进来就融入了这个集体，就像这样。我觉得你提升了我们的水平。简（Jen）和我在播客里讨论过这一点，我们当时有过这样一个时刻，大家环顾四周，然后我们说：这里只有我们几个女生。今天片场只有女生。
And how special that was in that moment. It was, it was. And I just, I thought it was just so wonderful, you know, sitting in the, you know, in the conference room and being able to, you know, get reactions from each of you. Of course, each woman coming from her different place and time, I remember Kate's line. She says, hi, I'm Kate, and I'm an owl.
那一刻是多么特别。确实如此，确实如此。我只是，我觉得太棒了，你知道的，坐在会议室里，能够听到你们每个人的反应。当然，每位女性都有着不同的背景和时期，我记得凯特（Kate）的台词。她说，嗨，我是凯特，我是一只猫头鹰。
Yeah. It was just so full of gold, and everybody having, you know, Mindy wanting an SUV, and what everybody wanted was so in character and such a reveal. I think the audience, I don't know, did the audience love the episode as much as we three do? I think they do. And people remind me a lot of Pam's dream to have a terrace that she can plant flowers on.
是的。这一集真是充满了金句，每个人都有，你知道的，明迪（Mindy）想要一辆SUV，每个人想要的东西都极其符合各自的角色设定，而且极具揭示性。我想观众，我不知道，观众和我们三个人一样喜欢这一集吗？我想他们是的。人们经常让我想起帕姆（Pam）想要一个可以种花的露台的梦想。
I get asked that question a lot. Do I think Pam ever got her terrace with flowers? Because that, and in the superfan episode, that's even more extended. Like her talking about that and what that means to her. I really loved that. That was based on a story that I told BJ Novak about reading a book when I was younger. It was like a choose your own adventure book. And the girl in the book had a house with like a, what do you call that? It almost looks like a little tower.
我经常被问到这个问题。我是否认为帕姆最终拥有了她的花草露台？因为在超级粉丝版中，这部分内容被进一步延伸了。就像她谈论那个以及那对她的意义。我真的很喜欢那个。那是基于我告诉B·J·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）的一个故事，我小时候读过一本书。那是一本“你自己决定结局”的书。书里的女孩住在一个有，你叫它什么来着？它看起来几乎像个小塔楼。
You know, where it's like a round room, kind call that? It almost looks like a little tower. You know, where it's like a round room, kind of a. Like a Rapunzel tower. A little bit like a Rapunzel tower. And the girl in the book would just, this was her special place and she got a new little sister, but she could go to her tower and daydream. And I used to think, oh, I hope one day I can have a house
你知道，就像一个圆形的房间，怎么说呢？像长发公主的高塔。有点像长发公主的高塔。书里的女孩就会，这是她的秘密基地，虽然她有了一个可爱的新妹妹，但她可以去她的塔楼里做白日梦。我以前常常想，哦，我希望有一天我能有一栋房子
with like my own tower room, and I'll just make it my own little library where I read books and be creative. It just sounded like so wonderful. And he turned that into a terrace with plants. So I think when I was doing those talking heads and as Pam, when I was talking about them, I was trying to like summon the little girl in me who wanted her tower house. Yeah.
里面有我自己的塔楼房间，我会把它变成我自己的小图书馆，我在那里读书并发挥创造力。听起来太美妙了。他把它变成了一个带植物的露台。所以我想当我拍摄那些访谈镜头时，作为帕姆，当我谈论这些时，我是在试着唤醒我内心那个想要塔楼房子的那个小女孩。是的。
Beautiful, beautiful. I think that's why it's so relatable too, because you, every little kid does have a dream like that, you know, of something that feels a little magical, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I love that it resonates with the audience, you know, and that you told the story so well. You know, it's not a lot to and that you told the story so well.
太美妙了，太美妙了。我想这就是为什么它也能引起共鸣，因为你，每个小孩子都有过那样的梦想，你知道的，那种感觉有点神奇的东西，对吧？对，对，对。我喜欢它能引起观众的共鸣，你知道的，而且你把这个故事讲得这么好。你知道，要求并不高，
It's not a lot to ask that you can have a room with some plants and a view. Yeah. And it's such a lovely dream. I think that really kicked off the whole poignancy of your dreams and then the whole art school subplot or the art training subplot, which was so great in the script and the way you played it
要求拥有一个带有植物和视野的房间并不是什么过分的要求。是的。这是一个多么可爱的梦想。我认为这真正拉开了你所有梦想的感人序幕，然后是整个艺术学校的情节线或艺术培训的情节线，这在剧本中非常棒，而且你的演绎方式也很棒，
that we know this is something that your hearts desire, but like you're already, even though Jan's trying to make it possible for you, you're already thinking of all the reasons why not. And how much it meant that Roy versus Jim, that Roy was never going to be on board with this, but who's your greatest supporter? Who's your biggest fan? Is Jim? And the whole poignancy of that arc
我们知道这是你内心深处渴望的，但你已经，尽管简正努力为你创造可能，你却已经在考虑所有不去的理由了。罗伊与吉姆相比，这意味着多么重大，罗伊永远不会支持这一点，但谁是你最大的支持者？谁是你最大的粉丝？是吉姆。整个弧光的动人之处在于
and how sometimes we all give up on our dreams at some point because it's just too hard. Or because you don't have the cheerleader in the place where you need it the most. I mean, if the person you're living with and spending your life with isn't lifting up your dreams and aspirations, that is a really hard wind to push against.
有时候我们所有人都会在某个时刻放弃梦想，因为这实在是太难了。或者因为你在最需要的地方找不到那个为你加油的人。我的意思是，如果你生活在一起、共度一生的人没有在鼓舞你的梦想和愿望，那将是一股非常难以逆风前行的阻力。
No, and I think that we began, you know, we the audience, we saw that and it relates to the episode that I did prior to this in The Secret when you find out that that crush that everybody's talking about Jim having is not in the past. It's right here right now. And how you are just, and you played it so beautifully, just like so secretly thrilled that it's today and then you're going down in the elevator together and then we and the audience are going keep them together, keep them together, please, please, please. We need this love to blossom.
不，而且我认为我们开始，你知道的，我们作为观众，我们看到了这一点，这与我之前在《秘密》那一集中所做的事情有关，当你发现每个人都在谈论的吉姆对你的暗恋并不是过去的事。它就在此时此地。而你是多么的，你演得太美妙了，就像是暗自为今天感到欣喜若狂，然后你们一起下电梯，接着我们和观众都在喊：让他们在一起，让他们在一起，求求你们，求求你们。我们需要这份爱绽放。
It just teed up everything so well that followed. Yeah. Well, the super fan episode has more of this Jim Pam arc. Yeah. It actually turns a little physical between Jim and Roy. This is not in the original episode. It happens down in the warehouse. Roy, you know, has heard that Jim told Pam
这为接下来发生的一切做好了极好的铺垫。是的。好吧，超级粉丝版有更多关于吉姆和帕姆这段感情脉络的内容。是的。吉姆和罗伊之间甚至发生了一些肢体冲突。这在原版剧集中是没有的。它发生在仓库里。罗伊，你知道的，听说吉姆告诉帕姆
she should take the job. Yeah. And he's ticked off about it. It starts with Roy shoving Jim. Well, we have a clip. Let's hear it. Let's hear it. Oh, boy.
她应该接受这份工作。是的。他对此很生气。一切从罗伊推搡吉姆开始。好吧，我们有一个片段。我们听听看。听听看。哦，天哪。
We're fighting. We're fighting. Hey, look at us, huh? All working together, getting along, united. Band of brothers. Like a union. Better. Hey, what the hell, man?
我们在打架。我们在打架。嘿，看着我们，啊？都在一起工作，和睦相处，团结一致。兄弟连。就像工会一样。更好。嘿，搞什么鬼，老兄？
You don't tell her what to do, all right? Come on, man. I was just giving her my opinion. Yeah, well, it has nothing to do with you. It's between her and me, all right? You got to respect that. Yeah. In front of all the guys in the warehouse, you got to respect that.
你别去对她指手画脚，好吗？得了吧，老兄。我只是在表达我的意见。是啊，这跟你没关系。这是我和她之间的事，好吗？你得尊重这一点。对，在仓库里所有伙计们的面前，你得尊重这一点。
It's amazing that because there's been all these undercurrents and all these rumors, and you know, I guess it was inevitable that it would get, you know, that it would come out at some point. Yeah. I can't remember. Was that in the original script? That was in the original script, but it did not make it into the original episode. Right, right. Oh, it's so important that it got to that hot level. Yeah. And Jim looks like When Roy yells at him,
真神奇，因为一直有各种暗涌和传闻，你知道的，我想这件事在某种程度上曝光也是不可避免的。对啊。我不记得了。那是原剧本里的吗？那是原剧本里的，但并没有剪进最初那一集里。对，对。哦，它能达到那个火爆的程度太重要了。对。而且吉姆看起来，当罗伊对大喊时，
you've got to respect that. He looks like someone just slapped him across the face, like just the embarrassment and being held accountable in a way, in front of everyone to his feelings. It's really powerful. Then Jim goes up to the kitchen and Pam's sitting there and he's like, really, you're not going gonna do it, huh? And she is, it's so awkward between them. And Pam has a line that now makes sense because she's like, how'd you
你不得不对此肃然起敬。他看起来就像刚被人当面扇了一耳光，那种尴尬，还有以某种方式当着所有人的面为自己的感情承担责任。这真的很有冲击力。然后吉姆走到厨房，帕姆坐在那里，他说，真的，你不会这么做，对吧？而她，他们之间的气氛太尴尬了。帕姆有一句台词现在听来很有道理，因为她说，你是怎么
know? Yeah. And you're like, well, Roy just, you know, slammed me to the ground. Exactly. Oh man. And you know, we saw that life, we could all understand what that life was gonna be like going forward, that flat line of a life going forward with Roy, as opposed to being with your best friend who really gets you. Yeah, who sees you. He sees you, you were seen by Jim.
知道的？对。然后你会觉得，好吧，罗伊刚刚，你知道的，把我按倒在地。一点没错。哦天哪。而且你知道，我们看到了那种生活，我们都能明白未来那种生活会是什么样，和罗伊在一起那种毫无波澜的生活，而不是和真正懂你的最好朋友在一起。对，那个懂你的人。他懂你，吉姆懂你。
I mean, such a fantastic relationship. I remember that is one thing that Greg talked to me about early on, he said, you know, you're going to really get into the weeds big time on this very precious storyline that we have. And he teased some of the story out to me at that point. You know, very delicate, very delicate stuff. And boy, I mean, and how that romance captured everybody in America. Man, we were rooting for you. Mm. I mean, yeah. Well, I just know in my own life,
我的意思是，这么棒的一段感情。我记得格雷格早期跟我谈过的一件事，他说，你知道的，你将要深入参与这个我们极为珍视的精彩故事情节中。当时他向我透露了一部分故事。你知道的，非常微妙，非常细腻的东西。天哪，我的意思是，这段浪漫是如何迷住全美所有人的。天哪，我们都在为你们加油。嗯。我是说，对啊。好吧，我只知道在我的生活中，
I feel such gratitude that, um, my parents supported my dream of being an actor. Like, my key relationships supported me. Like, I always felt like on each step of the journey, there was at least one person who was telling me I could do it. And even with that, it was hard, you know? Even with my parents saying,
我感到无比感恩，嗯，我的父母支持我当演员的梦想。就像，我的重要人际关系支持了我。就像，我总觉得在旅程的每一步，至少有一个人在告诉我，我能做到。即便如此，这也很艰难，你知道的？甚至在我父母说，
listen, we don't know if you'll ever make any money doing this or make a living, but if this is what is in your heart, then we're here for you. Oh, my God, what a gift. What a gift. Such a gift. Because I talk to a lot of acting students and creative students, and they're here for you. Oh my God, what a gift. What a gift. Such a gift. Because I talk to a lot of acting students and creative students and they don't have
听着，我们不知道你靠这个能不能赚到钱或者谋生，但如果这是你内心所想的，那我们就在这里支持你。哦，天哪，多么珍贵的礼物。多么珍贵的礼物。一份如此珍贵的礼物。因为我跟很多表演专业的学生和创意专业的学生聊过，他们都没有
that support. And I know how hard that is. And Pam didn't have it. I don't imagine like her parents were encouraging her to become an artist either, you know? She had a good job at Dunder Mifflin, why fool with it. Yeah. I'm sure. Exactly. No, but what with it. Yeah. I'm sure. Exactly. No, but what I know, it's wonderful.
这种支持。我知道这有多难。帕姆也没有。我想象不出她的父母会鼓励她成为一名艺术家，你知道的？她在邓德米夫林有一份好工作，干嘛要折腾呢。对。我敢说。一点没错。不，不过，我知道，这太棒了。
I had the same thing, my parents just said, do it, follow your heart and the rest will follow. We can't wait to see where it's all going. And you know, what a wonderful thing. I said that to my son all the time. I don't know where you're going, but can't wait to see. Yeah. Was it always directing for you?
我也有过同样的经历，我父母只是说，去做吧，跟随你的内心，剩下的水到渠成。我们迫不及待地想看看这一切会走向何方。而且你知道，这是多么美妙的事。我总是对我的儿子这么说。我不知道你要去哪里，但迫不及待地想看到。对。你一直以来都只想当导演吗？
Always, always. I mean, for like a nanosecond, I thought, oh, maybe I'll try being an actress. And then I got, my God, you have to have a skin like a rhinoceros. I don't know how you guys do it. I got kicked in the teeth a couple of times, and I said, okay, try that next. And my directors, who I was working with, said,
一直都是，一直都是。我是说，大约有一纳秒的时间，我想过，哦，也许我可以尝试当个演员。然后我挨了，天哪，你的脸皮得像犀牛皮一样厚。我不知道你们怎么做到的。我吃了几次闭门羹，然后我说，好吧，接下来试试这个。而那些跟我合作的导演说，
you tend to boss everybody else around. Maybe you want to think about directing instead of acting, because that might be a better fit. And that was in college. And then the head of the theater department at my college, he said, why don't you take a show, do a show. And so I did a show. I did Samuel Beckett's Endgame, had a blast.
你总是爱对其他人发号施令。也许你可以考虑当导演而不是当演员，因为那可能更适合你。那是在上大学的时候。然后我大学戏剧系的系主任说，你为什么不排个剧，排一部剧。于是我排了一部剧。我排了萨缪尔·贝克特的《终局》，玩得开心极了。
Wow. Yeah, really amazing play. And then he said, you should apply to Yale Drama School. And I went, oh no, that's, oh no. I was really pam on that. I was like, oh, that's not for me. That's Rich Blood. I said, they only take like four students.
哇。对，真的很棒的一部戏。然后他说，你应该申请耶鲁戏剧学院。而我说，哦不，那是，哦不。在这方面我简直就是帕姆。我想，哦，那不适合我。那是精英的血统。我说，他们只招收大约四个学生。
And he said, yeah, you could be one of those four. Oh man. So I applied and I couldn't believe it. I got my acceptance letter on April Fool's Day and I was so sure that my friends had pranked me. Had pranked you? And it was, I always consider that my first big break, you know, and yeah. So
他说，对，你就可以是那四个人之一。天哪。所以我申请了，简直不敢相信。我在愚人节那天收到了录取通知书，我当时笃信是我的朋友们在捉弄我。捉弄你？而且，我一直把那视为我的第一个重大突破，你知道的，所以
But you had someone that believed in you. I had someone that believed in me and was pushing me. So yeah, so yeah, I think we know that we know that Jim is going to continue to push Pam and who knows where that all could go. We captured some really wonderful moments because of that, not just Yorick, but everybody else and kind of where they were and what they were doing. How checked out they were of the whole process
但你有一个相信你的人。我有一个相信我并且推着我前进的人。所以，是的，所以，我想我们知道，我们知道吉姆会继续推动帕姆，谁知道这一切最终会走向何方。因为这一点，我们捕捉到了许多非常美好的时刻，不仅仅是约里克，还有其他人，以及他们身在何处、在做些什么。他们对整个流程是多么心不在焉，
or how committed they were. Or how judgy they were. How judgy they were. Do you ever think how fun it would be to just go back there again? If they talked to you guys about, wouldn't it be just dreamy to do a reunion show? I wish that I could, like,
还是多么投入。或者他们有多爱评头论足。多爱评头论足。你有没有想过，如果能再回到那个地方会有多有趣？如果他们跟你们谈过，拍个重聚秀不是很美妙吗？我希望我能像，
if I ever found like a genie in a bottle and I got three wishes, I think one of my wishes would be that I could go back and shoot an episode of The Office again, but like go back and shoot an episode of The Office again. But like, go back and like, reshoot Boys and Girls. Like, just experience it and live it. With this perspective after all these years.
如果我能找到一个神灯并得到三个愿望，我想我的愿望之一就是能够回到过去，再次拍摄一集《办公室》，但就像回到过去再次拍摄一集《办公室》一样。但就像，回到过去，比如，重新拍摄《男女有别》。就像，去体验它，去经历它。带着这些年之后的这种视角。
Yes. I would love to sit in a party planning committee scene. It would make me so happy. Yeah. Do you, does anybody come to you for that? Has an NPC come to you guys for that? I don't think we can get the whole group back together. And I also think like, I don't know if there's like a,
是的。我很乐意坐在一个派对策划委员会的场景里。那会让我开心极了。对。你，有没有人为此来找过你们？有NPC来找过你们谈这个吗？我觉得我们无法把整个团队重新聚齐了。而且我还觉得，我不知道是不是有个，
I don't want to undo the bow that we put on the end of it by like figuring out a way that all these people are back in the office again. Yeah. So we just treasure it, you know? But doing this podcast, it feels like we get to revisit it a little bit. Of course, of course.
我不想通过某种方式让所有人再次回到办公室，从而毁掉我们为它画上的完美句号。对。所以我们只是把它珍藏在心，你知道的？但做这个播客，感觉我们得以重新回顾它。当然，当然。
When does fast grocery delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without the grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit, but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that, actually, they will stay for dinner. Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer. So download the app and get delivery in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders.
通过Instacart享受快捷的杂货配送服务，在什么时候最重要？当你那款闻名遐迩的芥末籽土豆沙拉如果没有了芥末籽就不再闻名的时候。当烤肉架已经点燃，却没有什么可烤的时候。当亲家们决定，实际上他们要留下来吃晚饭的时候。这个夏天，Instacart为你备齐了所有杂货。赶快下载应用程序，最快60分钟即可送达。前三单还可享受0美元配送费。
Service fees exclusions and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over deliver. And I wanted to ask you, with your directing experience, when you joined the office, had you done any talking heads? Had you directed talking heads? No. And the talking heads thing was like a revelation, because I realized that, okay, I have an acting background and now I have to act the journalist.
服务费、排除条款和适用条件均适用。Instacart，使命必达的杂货配送服务。服务费、排除条款和适用条件均适用。Instacart，使命必达的杂货配送服务。而且我想问你，凭借你的导演经验，当你加入《办公室》时，你拍过访谈镜头吗？你导演过访谈镜头吗？没有。而且访谈镜头这东西简直就像是个启示，因为我意识到，好吧，我有表演背景，现在我得扮演记者了。
Yes. You know, I have to be watching you answer my questions and while I'm enjoying so much your answer and just seeing how that's gonna drop into the cut, I have to get ahead of it too at the same time and be thinking about what I can ask you that's gonna bring out something fun and surprising and new. And I would just get so mesmerized and that especially happened with Steve.
是的。你知道的，我必须看着你回答我的问题，虽然我非常享受你的回答，看着它将如何剪辑到成片中，但与此同时我也必须走在前面，思考我可以问你什么样的问题，才能带出有趣、惊艳且全新的内容。我常常会听得入迷，这种情况在和史蒂夫合作时尤其明显。
We're in the middle of Steve coming up with, you know, spouting some gold and I'm just like... So I have to ask you about one of his talking heads and I laughed so hard because it's so much longer in the superfan version than what originally aired. So basically, Jan has just kicked them out. He grabs the guys, he's like, we're gonna go down to the warehouse. And he has this talking head and let's hear it. Let's hear it.
我们在史蒂夫想出，你知道的，滔滔不绝说出一些金句的时候，我简直就……所以我必须问你关于他的一个访谈镜头，我笑得前仰后合，因为在粉丝珍藏版里，它比最初播出的版本要长得多。基本上，简刚刚把他们赶了出来。他抓住这群伙计，说道，我们要去仓库。然后他有这样一个访谈镜头，我们来听听。我们来听听。
We're gonna head down there. All of us guys and all of those guys together. We're gonna be one guy today. The office and the warehouse. The Woffus. Journey of self-discovery. Oh I think this can work out great because managing the warehouse is a very important part of my job and I haven't been there in months. Oh my god I know what such a great idea to go down below down to the depths. So great, so great. When you were doing the Talking Heads with Steve, were
我们要去下面。我们所有这些伙计和他们所有的那些伙计聚在一起。今天我们要成为同一个人。办公室和仓库。沃夫斯（Woffus）。自我发现之旅。哦，我觉得这结果会很棒，因为管理仓库是我工作非常重要的一部分，而且我已经好几个月没去过那里了。哦天哪，我知道去下面，去到深处，真是个绝妙的主意。太棒了，太棒了。当你和史蒂夫一起拍摄访谈镜头时，你
you prepared for how much off script he would sometimes go and then come back to the written script so seamlessly? No, I was I was just amazed and I think that's how I got so mesmerized and lost. Because I remember at one point, we literally looked at each other, and he's looking to me like, blank, blank, do you have another question for me? And I'm so completely caught up in his performance. And the way his mind worked, that we
对他的即兴发挥会有多少、以及他之后如何天衣无缝地回到剧本台词中，做好心理准备了吗？没有，我只是感到惊叹，我想这就是我为什么会听得入迷并迷失其中的原因。因为我记得有一次，我们俩字面意义上面面相觑，他看着我，眼神空洞，空白，你还有别的问题要问我吗？而我完全被他的表演迷住了。他脑子运转的方式，让我们
could go off on these crazy tangents, and then he would bring us back. I had an improv background, thank God. I think that every director needs that no matter what they're doing, but especially in this high stakes game of the office, you need your improv chops, you just have to have it because it's such a high wire act what you guys were doing. It's so dangerous.
可以偏离剧本去到那些疯狂的支线，然后他又能把我们拉回来。我有即兴表演的背景，谢天谢地。我认为无论导演在做什么，都需要这种能力，尤其是在《办公室》这场高风险的游戏中，你更需要你的即兴功底，你必须得有，因为你们当时在做的事就像在高空走钢丝一样。太危险了。
That's when it got great. It's like we didn't really know what was gonna happen. And you know, that we could just, who knows? You just gotta, I remember talking to Randy Einhorn, our DP about this and just saying, we just have to be ready. We have to be ready. We don't know what's gonna happen.
正因如此它才变得如此伟大。就像我们真的不知道接下来会发生什么。而且你知道，我们只能，谁知道呢？你只能，我记得跟我们的摄影指导兰迪·埃因霍恩聊过这件事，我就说，我们必须时刻准备着。我们必须准备好。我们不知道会发生什么。
We don't know, especially Steve or even Rainer. And you don't know what's gonna happen and just be ready to go to it and capture that gold. what I so admired in so many ways, the craft, especially boys and girls, what it seemed like even when someone was just in the deep background, there was something delicious happening that you wanted to rack focus to it and see what it was. It was just nonstop. Yeah. Everybody's on. Everyone's playing their
我们不知道，尤其是史蒂夫或雷纳。你不知道会发生什么，随时准备迎上去捕捉那些金子般的镜头。我极其钦佩的那些方面，那些精湛的技艺，特别是《男女有别》这一集，似乎即使有人只是站在深深的背景里，也会发生一些美妙的事情，让你想要把焦点转换过去看看到底是什么。简直一刻不停。对。每个人都在状态。每个人都在扮演自己的
part. I loved just seeing Kevin in the background once he said that he would back up Jim if Roy came for him. Just how Brian played like this tension throughout the episode. Like, whew. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It didn't break it. All of that. Just so delicious. And that's why I look back so nostalgically at it, because when do we get a chance to do something that incredibly layered and just everybody, I just felt like a composer and you guys, it's just all these Stradivarius violins playing at the same time.
角色。我太喜欢看凯文在背景里的表现了，自从他说过如果罗伊来找吉姆麻烦，他会支持吉姆之后。布莱恩在整集里展现那种紧张感的方式。就像，呼。对。对。对。它并没有破坏节奏。所有这一切。简直太美妙了。这就是为什么我回首往事时充满怀念，因为我们什么时候才有机会做出一部层次如此难以置信、而且每个人都……我当时觉得自己就像个指挥家，而你们，就像是一把接着一把同时演奏的斯特拉迪瓦里小提琴。
Denny, you mentioned that you had some improv background and I'm so curious, what does that mean? Well, when I was at Yale Drama School, I told you April Fools, I got pranked into going. And it was fantastic preparation because you had to do everything. The directors had to act. I had to pass an acting audition before I could get into the directing program, which I think was pretty brilliant that you could never put yourself in a position
丹妮，你提到你有过一些即兴表演的背景，我很好奇，那意味着什么？嗯，当我在耶鲁戏剧学院时，我告诉过你那是愚人节，我是被捉弄进去的。那是非常棒的训练，因为你必须什么都做。导演必须演戏。在我进入导演专业之前，我必须通过一次表演试镜，我觉得这相当高明，因为你永远不能让自己处于这样一种境地：
where you could be speaking to actors and not really understand what it is to be in those shoes. Wow, that's fantastic. So that's a very wonderful part of that program. But we did have a little cabaret theater and we did have a lot of classes in improvisation. And it just taught me so much. I always like to do an improv pass. And I tell my people, you know, let's make time for one word. And I tell the writers too, like, you know,
你在跟演员说话，却根本不理解身处他们的鞋子里是什么滋味。哇，太棒了。所以那是那个项目非常精彩的一部分。但我们确实有一个小卡巴莱剧场，我们有很多即兴表演的课。它教会了我太多。我总是喜欢做一次即兴发挥。我告诉我的团队，你知道的，我们留出时间来自由发挥一个词。我也告诉编剧们，你知道的，
we've got the written version. Let's do, I call it the wing ding, let's go. Let's just get a wing ding in the can, because something magical might happen and how delicious that's gonna be. And so, yeah, I think having that background really helped me to blend with you guys and the way your heads were working.
我们有了剧本版本。我们来做个，我称之为“点睛之笔”的环节，开始吧。我们只要把一个“点睛之笔”拍进罐头里就行，因为可能会发生神奇的事情，那该有多美妙。所以，是的，我认为拥有那种背景确实有助于我融入你们，融入你们大脑运转的方式。
It made a big difference. That's so cool. Well, I certainly felt like we had the ability to improv when you were on set. And there are some directors that you can just feel that ease. And I don't know if the word permission is the right word, but you just feel that ease. And I don't know if the word permission is the right word, but you just feel that creative dance.
这产生了巨大的影响。太酷了。好吧，我确实觉得当你在片场时，我们有即兴发挥的能力。有些导演会让你感到那种轻松自如。我不知道“允许”这个词是否合适，但你就是会感到那种轻松。我不知道“允许”这个词是否合适，但你就是能感受到那种创意的共舞。
And I remember that even with us gals in the conference room, because not all of that was scripted. There were a few little moments here and there where we got to play around. And poor Jan, most of it was at Jan's expense. I remember your great line, which I was talking about about aspirational dressing. And you said clearly Jan aspires to be a slut or a whore.
我记得甚至在我们这群姑娘在会议室里时也是这样，因为并非所有这些都有剧本。有几个零星的小片段，我们得以发挥一下。可怜的简，大部分都是以牺牲简为代价的。我记得你的那句精彩台词，我之前说过关于追求形象的着装。你说，显然简渴望成为一个放荡的女人或妓女。
But why? Because she has on black stockings. Black high heels. Yeah. Like, imagine. I know. And there is extra moments like as Jan's leaving and all the gals go to the window to watch her leave, Kelly says, I like her shoes and my character goes, I don't.
但为什么？因为她穿着黑丝袜。黑色高跟鞋。对。简直难以想象。我懂。而且还有一些额外的时刻，当简离开时，所有的姑娘都走到窗前看她离开，凯利说，我喜欢她的鞋子，而我的角色说，我讨厌。
It's like, why? They're very sensible low heel. Yes. No, I love that. Yeah. It's just a bridge too far for you. She crossed the line. She crossed the line and just slept them. No, there was just so much gold like that. My God.
就像，为什么？那是很实用低跟鞋。是的。不，我喜欢这样。对。对你来说这简直太过分了。她越界了。她越界了，简直是给她们一巴掌。不，像这样的精彩瞬间实在太多了。天哪。
Well, we also did have a pretty big stunt with you. Now, we never had stunts, hardly ever. But you had this one where Michael has the forklift and he's trying to put a box on a shelf and then he knocks them all and they domino and they crash. And we were so curious about shooting that. Did you guys get it in one? We got it in one.
好吧，我们当时也拍了一个对你来说相当大的特技。现在，我们从来没有过特技，几乎从来没有。但你有这样一个特技，迈克尔开着叉车，他正试图把一个箱子放到货架上，然后他撞翻了所有的箱子，它们像多米诺骨牌一样坍塌了。我们对拍摄那个镜头非常好奇。你们是一条过的吗？我们是一条过的。
Because, you know, as successful as the show was, you know, we were always up against it in terms of time and money. And also, I was pretty sure that it would deaden if we had to do take two. So I told everybody we're going to get this in one take. So let's just sort of loosely rehearse it. And what happens, happens. And I think the art department had helped me.
因为，你知道的，尽管这部剧很成功，你知道的，我们在时间和金钱方面总是捉襟见肘。而且我也很确凿地知道，如果我们必须拍第二条，效果就会大打折扣。所以我告诉所有人，我们这一条必须一条过。所以让我们大致排练一下。发生什么就发生什么。我想美术部门帮了我。
We kind of rigged the shelves so that they would domino down. But, and you know, Steve was great. He had a pretty good idea of how to make that thing swing. But yeah, that was one take. And then what was so challenging was that as the guys further destroyed the warehouse, you know, we had to shoot that in continuity, you know, getting the styrofoam peanuts down and all the mess that we were making had to be in continuity because we were progressively destroying the workplace. And then Dwight's spud gun
我们把货架做了些手脚，好让它们像多米诺骨牌一样倒塌。但是，你知道的，史蒂夫太棒了。他对于如何让那东西晃动有着相当不错的想法。不过，是的，那是条过。然后极具挑战性的是，随着男人们进一步破坏仓库，你知道的，我们必须按连续性拍摄，你知道的，让聚苯乙烯泡沫塑料花生落下来，我们制造的所有混乱都必须保持连贯，因为我们正在逐步摧毁这个工作场所。然后是德 Dwight 的土豆枪，
that goes into Daryl's window as well. I missed that in the shorter cut. That was so great. I remember in episodes following this episode that Daryl's window was being repaired and then there was no real context for it. But it was because Dwight shot the window with his potato gun. Maybe in our dreams, who are all imagining
它也射穿了达里尔的窗户。我在较短的剪辑版里漏掉了那个。太棒了。我记得在这一集之后的剧集里，达里尔的窗户一直在修理，当时并没有真正的上下文。但那是由于德怀特用他的土豆枪击中了窗户。也许在我们的梦想中，大家都在想象
we'd get to do a longer version and keep all the gold. I remember inviting you and Krasinski into the edit room once because I was like, oh my God, I gotta make all these hard choices. We gotta get this down to airtime. Were we helpful? You were very helpful. Really?
我们能拍一个更长的版本并保留所有的精彩片段。我记得曾邀请你和卡拉辛斯基去过一次剪辑室，因为我想，哦天哪，我必须做出所有这些艰难的选择。我们必须把片长压缩到播出时长。我们有帮上忙吗？你们非常帮忙。真的吗？
Oh, I'm glad to hear that. Because it was so much about you. I think it may, I don't know if it was the first episode I did or the second, but I just thought, look, you guys are inhabiting this. Let's see what you're thinking about this. And you will be remembering things that you did, and did we capture it the way you remembered it, you know?
哦，很高兴听到这个。因为这很大程度上关乎你们。我想这可能是我拍的第一集或第二集，但我只是觉得，听着，你们是这些角色的化身。让我们看看你们对这有什么看法。你们会记起你们做过的事情，我们捕捉到的是否如你们所记忆的那样，你知道的？
Oh my gosh, I don't remember you doing that, but I have no doubt that you did and that was something that they did on the show a lot was invite the actors to come into the editing room, which has never happened to me again. Really? Yeah, no, no. And we didn't know that, we thought that was pretty normal.
哦天哪，我不记得你做过那件事，但我毫不怀疑你确实这么做了，那是他们在剧里经常做的一件事，就是邀请演员进剪辑室，这在我身上再也没有发生过。真的吗？对啊，没有，没有。而我们当时并不知道，我们以为这挺正常的。
So our jobs after were like, are we, Yeah, no, no. And we didn't know that. We thought that was pretty normal. So our jobs after were like, are we, does anyone want us to watch some of the dailies? They're like, no. Isn't that terrible? So many of the things that were set in place and the procedures and the rhythms were designed to succeed. And there's a reason why they just,
所以我们之后的反应是，我们，对啊，没有，没有。而我们当时并不知道。我们以为这挺正常的。所以我们之后的反应是，我们，有人想让我们看毛片吗？他们说，不。这难道不是很糟糕吗？很多既定的事情、流程和节奏都是为了成功而设计的。这就有一个原因，为什么它们就是，
and I often, I mean, I wonder like, how did that begin? Did Greg say this is the way we're doing it or was it Ken coming in and saying this is the way we're gonna do it? Because it's clearly, it's all based on success. We're all in this together. I really think it's Greg. I mean, you know, even from the very beginning of the show,
而且我经常，我是说，我纳闷，那是怎么开始的？是格雷格说这就是我们的做事方式，还是肯来之后说这就是我们要做的？因为很显然，这一切都是基于成功。我们都在这条船上。我真的认为是格雷格。我是说，你知道的，甚至从这部剧一开始，
if someone had a thought, he's just a curious person. I remember him going to the accountants in the production trailer and asking their input about what they thought of this scene. Did it seem realistic? And I think he encouraged that in his whole group. I still remember Dave Rogers telling me one time, Ange, we had just filmed Casino Night. And he was like, Ange, I want you to come and see the take where you slap Dwight. He was like, I don't know if you know this, but Matt Sohn caught your little smile after the slap.
如果有人有什么想法，他是一个充满好奇心的人。我记得他去生产拖车里找会计师，询问他们对这个场景有什么看法。这看起来真实吗？我想他在他的整个团队中都鼓励这种做法。我仍然记得有一次戴夫·罗杰斯对我说，安芝，我们刚拍完《赌场之夜》。他说，安芝，我希望你来看你扇德怀特那一巴掌的镜头。他说，我不知道你知不知道，但马特·索恩捕捉到了你挨巴掌后的一丝微笑。
And he said, and I put it in. And I was like, that's just so special. And so I went into the editing bay and I saw that. And I just don't think that happens very often. And I think like, that's just so special. And so I went into the editing bay and I saw that. And I just don't think that happens very often. And I think that was Greg. Greg made us all a team like that. It doesn't.
他说，我把它剪进去了。当时我就觉得，这太特别了。于是我走进剪辑室看到了那一幕。我觉得这种事不会经常发生。而且我认为，那太特别了。于是我走进剪辑室看到了那一幕。我觉得这种事不会经常发生。我认为那是格雷格。格雷格让我们所有人都成了一个这样的团队。确实不会。
I love having actors in the edit room when I'm ready to show it to them. If they can take it, because you have to ask them first, don't be afraid. If we have a lot more to shoot, I don't want them to be freaked out for the going forward at the choices they've made. You know, I have to always say,
当我准备向演员展示时，我很喜欢让他们进剪辑室。如果他们能接受的话，因为你必须先问他们，不要害怕。如果我们还有很多要拍的，我可不想让他们因为自己做出的选择而对未来的拍摄感到惊慌失措。你知道的，我必须总是问，
are you someone who can, are you strong enough? Can you take it? Can you take it? But once it's well after the fact, then, you know. I like to see playback on set sometimes. I do too. Because my training, when I came out to LA, I ended up studying with a really great teacher
你是一个能接受的人吗，你够坚强吗？你能承受吗？你能承受吗？但一旦过了很久之后，那么，你知道的。我有时也喜欢在片场看回放。我也喜欢。因为我的训练，当我刚来到洛杉矶时，我最终跟着一位非常棒的老师学习，
who was really helping me with like on-camera auditioning when you'd have to go on tape. And he would have us do the audition on tape and then we would sit in class and we would all watch the auditions. But you were only allowed to comment on your own. You were not allowed to give notes to other actors. And I have to say like so often so often, like, watching it back,
他真的在帮我进行镜头前的试镜，也就是你需要录像的那种。他会让我们把试镜录下来，然后我们在课堂上一起观看试镜。但你只被允许评论你自己的。你绝对不允许对其他演员提出意见。我必须说，很多时候，很多时候，就像回看时，
I was like, oh yeah, I see it. My face is in my script too much. I didn't have the first three lines memorized. That moment of decision that I thought was powerful in my head is not reading. I need to try something else. So when I'm on set, like if I'm wondering, like am I nailing this?
我会想，哦是的，我看到了。我的脸在剧本里陷得太深了。我没有把前三台词背熟。我脑海里觉得很有力量的那个决定瞬间，在画面里根本没有体现出来。我得尝试点别的。所以当我在片场时，如果我在想，我这是演对了吗？
Am I giving this what it's supposed to have? I'll ask, can I watch playback of that last one? Because I can just see it. I can see that what needs to be there isn't there, and I'll be like, oh, I got it. Sometimes, like for me, but a lot of times, I find that like directors and producers are kind of scared to show actors playback,
我有没有演出它该有的效果？我会问，我能看一眼刚才那条的回放吗？因为我能看到。我能看出该有的东西不在那儿，然后我会想，哦，我明白了。有时候，对我来说，但很多时候，我发现导演和制片人有点害怕向演员展示回放，
because I think maybe some people spiral, but I find it really helpful. I think it is incredibly helpful. I just finished this project in the UK, and it was like, you know, we were like a tower of babble. There were like five different languages being spoken on set. And it was so great for some of the actors. I said, just come and sit for a second, and let me show you what you did.
因为我想有些人可能会情绪失控，但我发现这真的很有帮助。我认为这极其有帮助。我刚刚在英国完成了一个项目，就像，你知道的，我们就像一座巴别塔。片场有好几种不同的语言在说。这对一些演员来说太棒了。我说，过来坐一会儿，让我看看你刚才做了什么。
They think, they're like, I got it. You know, it's so much faster than giving a note in some cases. It's like, oh geez, I thought, okay, got it. Yeah, I love it too. And then you'll go nail it. You love it too, yeah. Yeah, I do.
他们会想，他们会觉得，我懂了。你知道的，在某些情况下，这比给笔记要快得多。就像，哦天哪，我想，好吧，懂了。是的，我也很喜欢。然后你就会完美搞定。你也喜欢，对吧？是的，我喜欢。
Cause it's just like what you said, it's immediate. You just see it right away. You're like, oh, why am I, I'm like looking at the plate that's about to break. Right. Maybe I shouldn't be anticipating this, whatever it is that's coming across my face. Right, right.
因为就像你说的，这是立竿见影的。你马上就能看到。你会想，哦，为什么我，我怎么像是在盯着那个快要碎掉的盘子。对。也许我不应该表现出期待，无论那是什么划过我脸庞的情绪。对，对。
God, how fun our jobs are. Really? I know. So fun, right? You know, I don't know anything that's more fun. I mean, everybody in Hollywood's trying to pivot right now. I'm like, you know, how could we possibly do anything else when we love it so much?
天哪，我们的工作多有趣啊。真的吗？我知道。太有趣了，对吧？你知道，我不知道还有什么比这更有趣的了。我是说，好莱坞的每个人现在都在寻求转型。我在想，你知道的，既然我们这么热爱它，怎么可能去做别的事呢？
What's your favorite part of directing? Do you love pre-production? Do you love shooting? Do you love editing? What do you like? You know, it so much. What's your favorite part of directing? Do you love pre-production? Do you love shooting? Do you love editing? What do you like? You know, it's crazy. I really love all of it. In the prep, it's such a heady time because you can dream and invent and imagine, and
你最喜欢导演的哪个部分？你喜欢前期制作吗？你喜欢拍摄吗？你喜欢剪辑吗？你喜欢什么？你知道，太疯狂了。我实际上所有部分都喜欢。在筹备阶段，那是一段令人兴奋的时期，因为你可以梦想、发明和想象，然后
then your dreams get kicked in the teeth a little bit because there's not the money or time to do what you're dreaming. But I love the prep, and for me, it's all about the prep. And the more prepped I am, we'll have much more fun when we're shooting. Because when we're shooting, it's like, you know, we've really thought about this. It's like, yeah, well, you know, you need that drawing and that notebook of drawings. You know, we will have already thought about that. We're not always blessed to have such a wonderful prop, you know, man in our pocket.
你的梦想会被现实狠狠泼一盆冷水，因为没有钱或时间来做你梦想的事。但我喜欢筹备，对我来说，一切都在于筹备。筹备得越充分，我们在拍摄时就会越开心。因为当我们在拍摄时，就像，你知道的，我们真的仔细思考过这个。就像，是的，好吧，你知道的，你需要那张图纸和那个画着图画的笔记本。你知道的，我们那时就已经想过这些了。我们并不总是那么幸运，能在口袋里揣着这样一个绝妙的道具，你知道的。
I love the shooting. I love the thrill of it. I think what makes our work a little addicting is that you look at a schedule, you know, and you go, oh my God, I've got to do this, this, this, and this today, and we'll never make it. And then somehow we do. And at the end of the day, you're so, as the Brits say, chuffed, like, man, we did it. High five all around. You know, it's like, we actually survived this. And I can't think of any other craft or business where at the end of the day, you get to have share that joy with everybody. Like we faced the impossible today and all these disastrous things happened and we still
我喜欢拍摄。我喜欢那种肾上腺素飙升的感觉。我认为让我们的工作有点让人上瘾的是，你看一眼日程表，你知道的，然后你会想，哦天哪，我今天得拍这个、这个、这个还有这个，我们绝对拍不完。然后不知怎么的，我们做到了。而在一天结束时，你感觉自己，正如英国人所说，非常得意（chuffed），就像，天哪，我们做到了。击掌庆祝。你知道的，就像，我们居然活下来了。我想不出还有什么其他行业或生意，在一天结束时，你能和大家一起分享这种喜悦。就像我们今天面对了不可能完成的任务，所有这些灾难性的事情都发生了，我们依然
crushed. That's part of the fun. You have to do that. Absolutely. I mean, that's what we become production junkies. We have to keep going back for that high. The whole time you were telling that story, I thought of this moment that I always say to my daughter when we think something can't happen, like, how are we going to pull this
大获成功。这也是乐趣的一部分。你必须得经历那些。绝对的。我是说，这就是为什么我们成了制作工作狂。我们不得不不断回去寻找那种高潮。当你讲那个故事的时候，我一直在想这样一个时刻，每当觉得某事不可能发生时，我总是对女儿说，比如，我们该怎么把这个
off? There's that movie Shakespeare in Love, and everything's going wrong with the play. They're like, how's that going to happen? He goes, it's the theater. It's a mystery. No, I love that. Was that, who was that that said that? Jeffrey Rush? Jeffrey Rush. Yes.
办成呢？有部电影叫《莎翁情史》，戏剧的排练过程中一切都出了问题。他们问，这该怎么收场？他说，这是戏剧。是个谜。不，我喜欢那个。那是，那是谁说的？杰弗里·拉什？杰弗里·拉什。是的。
It was Jeffrey Rush. It was Jeffrey Rush. It's a mystery. Yeah, it's a mystery. I love that. I've said that on set a couple times. Yeah. I do love that. Wow. Do you still direct theater?
是杰弗里·拉什。是杰弗里·拉什。是个谜。是的，是个谜。我喜欢那个。我在片场说过好几次了。是的，我真的很喜欢。哇。你现在还导演戏剧吗？
No, sadly I don't. And you know what? I'm so keen to give it another whack. I've been reading about this wonderful play on Broadway that Sarah Snook is starring in. And they're using a lot of cameras. And I thought this is such an exciting place, you know, a new way of telling a story, new media where cameras meet performance, live performance. And I'm dying to get to New York to see it. And I just, I would love to do something like that.
不，遗憾的是没有了。你知道吗？我非常渴望再尝试一次。我一直在读关于百老汇一部由莎拉·斯努克主演的精彩戏剧的报道。他们用了大量的摄像机。我觉得这是一个如此令人兴奋的地方，你知道的，一种讲故事的新方式，将摄像机与表演、现场表演相结合的新媒体。我渴望去纽约亲眼看看。我真的，我很想做那样的事。
That would really be up my alley. And I am dying to see how they're doing it because I keep hearing there's moments where they go in close on her hands. She's playing about six, eight parts. It sounds like a tour de force. But yeah, I'd love to do theater again. Anytime, anywhere.
那绝对符合我的胃口。我太渴望看到他们是怎么做到的了，因为我一直听说有些时刻他们会近距离特写她的双手。她一个人要演大约六到八个角色。听起来真是一场惊人的考验。不过，是的，我很想再次涉足戏剧。任何时间，任何地点。
I would really love it. Now I'm writing and doing some personal projects that I'm into. And I just finished this massive project. Did I mention this? In the UK with Guy Ritchie. No, what are you doing? It's called Young Sherlock. And Guy Ritchie is the executive producer.
我真的非常想。现在我在写作，并且在做一些我感兴趣的个人项目。我刚刚完成了一个庞大的项目。我提到了吗？在英国和盖·里奇合作。不，你在做什么？它叫《年轻的夏洛克》。盖·里奇是执行制片人。
It's like we go back from the movies, you know, with Robert Downey and Jude Law, we go back. And now Sherlock is just a young man at Oxford. And God, we had a blast. We had such a great cast. I got reunited with Colin Firth, with I'd done a movie and we had Joseph Fiennes, and then his nephew, Hero Fiennes, gonna be a huge star, plays Sherlock, and it was super fun to try to
就像我们回溯到那些电影之前，你知道的，罗伯特·唐尼和裘德·洛演的电影，我们追溯到更早。现在夏洛克只是牛津大学的一个年轻人。天哪，我们玩得太开心了。我们的演员阵容太棒了。我跟科林·费尔斯重聚了，我以前拍电影时和他合作过，我们还有约瑟夫·费因斯，然后是他的侄子，英雄·费因斯，他将成为超级巨星，饰演夏洛克，尝试以
shoot in Guy Ritchie's style, you know, which is so crazy and muscular and completely nutball. We had just the best time. I literally just got back from that. I can't wait to watch that. That's coming in the fall. Oh, man. I think Amazon's thinking of it as kind of a big temple, fingers crossed. We had a blast, so we hope the audience does.
盖·里奇的风格进行拍摄真的超级有趣，你知道的，那种疯狂、充满张力而且完全神经质的风格。我们度过了最棒的时光。我字面意义上刚刚从那边回来。我等不及要看了。那将在秋天上映。哦，天哪。我想亚马逊正把它视为什么重头戏，祈祷一切顺利。我们玩得很开心，所以希望观众也会喜欢。
Well, you also had reunited with John Krasinski on season two of Jack Ryan. How was that? Oh, my god. Well, he advocated for it, and I was so grateful, because I think he just really needed a familiar face, you know, at that point. And we'd had such a good time together. And that show was crazy and really hard.
好吧，你还在《杰克·莱恩》第二季中与约翰·卡拉辛斯基重聚了。感觉怎么样？哦，天哪。嗯，他是力荐我去的，我非常感激，因为我觉得在那时他真的需要一个熟悉的面孔，你知道的。而且我们之前合作得非常愉快。那部剧极其疯狂而且非常艰难。
And we were in all these, like, super dangerous locations. I was going to say, they filmed that all over the place. Oh, my God. Well, we were in the jungle. You know, we had poisonous snakes and poisonous spiders and everything and 120 degrees. And then we were in Moscow and New York and London. It was completely nuts. And everything that could go wrong did go wrong. And so, you know, naturally we needed to laugh our way
我们身处所有这些，你知道的，极其危险的外景地。我正想说，他们到处取景拍摄。哦，天哪。嗯，我们在丛林里。你知道的，我们有毒蛇、毒蜘蛛以及各种东西，温度高达120度。然后我们在莫斯科、纽约和伦敦。简直完全是神经病。所有可能出错的事情都出错了。所以，你知道的，我们自然需要一路笑着度过
through it or otherwise we would have jumped off a cliff. It was really hard. That was a blast. And he's asked me back a couple of times. It's never quite worked out, but that turned out to be such a big thing, you know, big franchise for him. And how fun, knowing him as Jim, to see him develop into this huge leading man.
难关，否则我们就要跳悬崖了。真的很难。那次玩得很开心。而且他邀请我回去过好几次。虽然一直没能成行，但那对他的事业来说成了一件大事，你知道的，一个巨大的特许经营项目。而且很有趣的是，认识作为吉姆的他，看着他成长为这样一个超级男主角。
Yeah. I mean, we all knew he had that in him. I remember one time you said, I mean, look at him. Do you remember that? Like, look at this guy. I mean, of course. And see him develop as a director. Because we'd wake up every morning and we'd talk about the box office for a quiet place.
是的。我是说，我们都知道他身上有那种特质。我记得有一次你说，我是说，看看他。你还记得吗？就像，看看这家伙。我是说，当然。而且看着他作为导演成长。因为我们每天早晨醒来，都会谈论《寂静之地》的票房。
And that was just exploding. We would like to shake our heads and go, oh my God, John, here you go. Here you go. You're a big ass director now. Well, I remember on the set, I would say to John, John, I think you're our Tom Hanks. Like, this is your bosom buddies.
那简直是在爆炸式增长。我们会忍不住摇头说，哦天哪，约翰，厉害了。厉害了。你现在是个了不起的大导演了。好吧，我记得在片场时，我会对约翰说，约翰，我觉得你就是我们的汤姆·汉克斯。就像，这是你的《亲密伙伴》。
Like, this is literally just the start of something for you. Like, I know people will always know you as Jim Halpert and all of that, but like, when people think of Tom Hanks, they don't think of bosom buddies. They think of everything else Tom Hanks has done. I was like, I think you're going to be our Tom Hanks, John. I really do. Boy, that was astute. Yeah.
就像，这字面意义上只是你某种传奇的开始。就像，我知道人们永远会认得你是吉姆·霍尔珀特以及所有那些，但是，当人们想到汤姆·汉克斯时，他们不会想到《亲密伙伴》。他们想到的是汤姆·汉克斯拍过的所有其他作品。我当时就说，我觉得你会成为我们的汤姆·汉克斯，约翰。我真的这么觉得。天哪，太有远见了。对。
That was astute. Yeah, what a meteoric rise, too. Just the best. Yeah. Just the best. I texted him. I watched A Quiet Place on an airplane. Probably not the best place.
太有远见了。是的，而且上升速度也太迅猛了。简直棒极了。对。简直棒极了。我给他发了短信。我在飞机上看了《寂静之地》。可能不是个好地方。
I was so freaked out on the plane and having big reactions. This lady next to me was like, what is happening with you? But yeah, it's just been such a joy to watch our cast mates have these new chapters of their life and we all still have a text thread, the cast. I was gonna ask you if you guys did. Yeah, it's called the Office Peeps and we check in on it.
我在飞机上吓坏了，反应特别大。我旁边这位女士就问，你这是怎么了？不过，是的，看着我们的演员伙伴们迎来他们生活中的这些新篇章，真的太令人高兴了，而且我们所有演员都还有一个群聊。我正想问你们有没有呢。对，叫“办公室伙伴”（Office Peeps），我们会经常在上面交流。
And it means so much to us that we have each other still through all of these different seasons of life and we check in and BJ always says office family forever. Oh, I love that. I know. I love that. Well, you know, because I think even at the time you all knew that you were creating something
这意味着对我们而言，在生活的各个不同阶段，我们依然拥有彼此，这意义重大，我们会互相问候，BJ总是说“办公室大家庭，永不散场”。哦，我喜欢这样。我知道。我喜欢这样。好吧，你知道的，因为我觉得即使在当时，你们大家也都知道你们正在创造一些
extraordinarily special and that the likelihood of it coming again was slim, and that somehow everything was firing on all cylinders, and that you had to just sort of revel in your time. And I just, I think everybody felt that. Everybody knew that, and you know, how joyous that was. And this group of people too, we all knew each other well before anyone knew us. You know, like we journeyed that other part of this industry, which is being at the very
非凡特别的东西，而且它再次发生的可能性微乎其微，并且不知何故一切都在全速运转，你只需要尽情享受你的时光。而且我，我想每个人都有这种感觉。每个人都知道这一点，而且，你知道的，那是多么快乐。而且这群人也是，早在任何人认识我们之前，我们就已经很了解彼此了。你知道的，就像我们经历了这一行业的另一部分，那就是从最
beginning and it just builds a lifelong friendship in you. I remember one of my good friends from back home in St. Louis, when I was getting married, she said, I'm sorry to be nerdy, but are there going to be any famous people at your wedding? And I said, no, not really. No, I don't think there's going to be any famous people. And she said, oh, the cast of The Office isn't coming. And I said, oh no, they're coming. Sorry, I don't think of them as famous people.
初开始，这会在你身上铸就终生的友谊。我记得我在圣路易斯的一位老家好友，当我结婚时，她说，抱歉我问得这么书呆子气，你的婚礼上会有什么名人吗？我说，没有，真的没有。不，我觉得不会有什么名人。然后她说，哦，办公室的演员不来吗？我说，哦不，他们来。抱歉，我没把他们当成名人。
Yeah. That's hilarious. And I think that still holds true to this day. That's exactly right. Even as people are household names to us, they're just those people who were touching up their noses themselves on set or helping you buy your Honda. It's like, I remember Phyllis looking at cars online with me.
是的。太搞笑了。我想这种感觉直到今天依然如此。完全正确。即使对我们来说这些人都是家喻户晓的名字，他们也只是那些在片场自己补妆或者帮你买本田车的人。就像，我记得菲利丝和我一起在网上看车。
Yeah. Things like that. I completely love that. These are, what does BJ say, friends forever? Office family forever. Yeah. There you go. I just had one thing, since we all rewatched
是的。诸如此类的事。我简直太爱了。这些是，BJ是怎么说的，永远的朋友？办公室大家庭，永不散场。对。就是这样。我只有一件事，既然我们都重温了
this super fan version of Boys and Girls, I know there was a moment that made me laugh every time that got me. It was my favorite moment and it's such a tiny moment. And the way you shot it is so brilliant. Michael has everyone in the warehouse seated in a circle and he's like, guy talk. And he has his shirt on buttoned and he says, hassle off. Yes. He's like, I was off. But the thing that got me is I only saw a group of men and then Madge leans forward and
这一集《男女有别》的粉丝珍藏版，我知道有个时刻每次都把我逗笑，戳中了我的笑点。那是我的最爱，而且是一个非常微小的时刻。你拍它的方式太绝了。迈克尔让仓库里的每个人围成一圈坐着，他说，男人之间的谈话。他解开衬衫扣子说，我刚才脱掉了。但真正戳中我的是，我只看到了一群男人，然后麦奇（Madge）探身向前说，
says, Hey, do you want me to go? And he's like, um, no, why would I? And she's like, I'll go. I know. I love that moment. I love that moment. I, you know, I, it was pretty easy lens wise for her to just lean back. And we, I remember thinking like we have to hide her until that moment. It's so good. I love that you love that moment, but yeah, there's so many.
嘿，你想让我走吗？然后他说，嗯，不，我为什么要？她接着说，那我走了。我懂。我太喜欢那个时刻了。我太喜欢那个时刻了，你知道的，从镜头来看，她往后靠其实挺简单的。而且，我记得当时想，我们必须把她藏起来，直到那个时刻。太棒了。我很高兴你也喜欢那个时刻，不过，是的，这样的时刻太多了。
I mean, there's so many. Do you have a favorite moment in your rewatch of this? God, again, so many. Oh God, I mean, it's just like the whole episode. There's never a moment where I felt let down. I mean, rain doing angels in the snow with the styrofoam that Michael has emptied all the bags. And there were so many moments like that.
我是说，真的有太多了。你在重看这部剧时，有没有最喜欢的片段？天哪，同样地，有太多了。噢，天哪，我的意思是，就像整集一样。从来没有哪个时刻让我觉得失望。我是说，雷恩在雪地里用迈克尔清空所有袋子里的泡沫塑料做天使。有太多这样的时刻了。
Just loved every bit of it. I can tell you one of my favorites is that first shot of all the office guys at the top of the staircase, and they're looking down at like the hustle and bustle and the machinery and the music of the warehouse. And I love that line when Dwight says, "'Remember on Lost when they met the others?' And that's what it's like. And I like that line when Dwight says, remember on Lost when they met the others?
每一个部分我都超爱。我可以告诉你，我最喜欢的其中一个镜头，就是所有办公室的伙计们站在楼梯顶端，俯视着仓库的繁华喧嚣、机器和音乐。我超喜欢德怀特说的那句台词：“还记得《迷失》里他们遇到‘其他人’的时候吗？”那种感觉就是这样。我喜欢德怀特说的那句，还记得《迷失》里他们遇到其他人时吗？
And that's what it's like. And Michael has that line where he says, it's like meet the Fokkers, but it's like meet the warehouse. It's like, Michael, this warehouse has been here. But they're all almost discovering this world for the first time. And the way you shot it, they really are almost descending into this other place.
而那种感觉就是这样。迈克尔有一句台词是，这就像是《拜见岳父大人》，不过这是拜见仓库。这就好比，迈克尔，这个仓库一直都在这儿。但他们几乎都是第一次发现这个世界。而且你们拍摄它的方式，真的让他们几乎像是降落到了另一个地方。
Right. I remember that with Dwight. Going down into the warehouse, going down at the balls, it was so masculine down there, you know, so much testosterone down there and it was so, you know, and Michael's saying, you know, I'm call, uh, white collar, blue collar, I'm collar blind. everybody goes. Exactly. It was so fun. Well, Denny, we love to end our interviews with the call sheet questions. You know, these were the questions that were on the back of the call sheet in the later seasons of the show and we would get to know a crew member or a cast member.
对。我记得德怀特的那场戏。走下去进到仓库，走到那些球场，那里真是太有男人味了，你知道的，那里有那么多的雄性激素，而且，你知道的，迈克尔说，你知道的，我是白领，蓝领，我是领子盲。大家都去了。没错。太有趣了。好了，丹妮，我们喜欢用通告单问题来结束采访。你知道，这些问题就是剧集后期时，通告单背面的那些问题，通过它们我们可以更多地了解剧组工作人员或演员。
And so here we go. Are you ready? I'm ready. What was your first entertainment job? You know, I got a job as an actress. That was my first entertainment job. A little municipal theater in Minneapolis, St. Paul, called The Stagecoach. It was a summer theater, and I got that job
那么，我们开始吧。准备好了吗？我准备好了。你的第一份娱乐行业工作是什么？你知道的，我得到了一份演员的工作。那是我的第一份娱乐行业工作。明尼阿波利斯圣保罗的一个小型市政剧院，叫“驿马车”。那是一个夏季剧院，我得到了那份工作，
while I was still in high school. But it was an actual paying job. It was incredible. I was actually a little late to get into college because of it. So yeah, that's when I thought I could be an actress. Did you have to sing and dance for that part? I had to sing and dance.
当时我还在读高中。但那是一份真正有薪水的工作。太不可思议了。因为这个，我上大学实际上还稍微迟到了。所以，是的，那就是我认为自己可以成为一名演员的时候。为了那个角色，你必须唱歌跳舞吗？我必须唱歌跳舞。
Yeah. I had to sing and dance. It was super fun. But I was kind of terrible. We were doing old melodramas and stuff like that. If you stuck with it for the very long, you would develop all these loathsome habits. You had to get out fast. All right.
是的。我必须唱歌跳舞。超级有趣。但我其实有点糟糕。我们当时在演老式情节剧之类的内容。如果你在那儿待太久，就会养成所有这些令人讨厌的习惯。你得赶紧离开。好了。
Second question. Do you speak any other languages? I do. I do, but one I don't even know how to use, which is German. I speak German. I was very lucky in my grammar school that there was this extraordinary woman that started offering German to us in fourth grade.
第二个问题。你会说其他语言吗？我会的。我会，但其中有一种我都不知道怎么用，那就是德语。我会说德语。我很幸运，在我的文法学校里，有一位非凡的女性从四年级开始向我们教授德语。
So I took it and then got to high school and thought, well, I'll just keep this up. Then got to college and thought, I'll just keep this up. Finally, like when I was scratching around in New York trying to get arrested, I got a job translating. So it was a useful side hustle, but German. If you get me really drunk,
所以我选修了它，到了高中时我想，好吧，我会继续学这个。然后到了大学又想，好吧，我会继续学这个。最后，就像我在纽约四处碰壁、试图找点事情做的时候，我得到了一份翻译的工作。所以这是一份有用的副业，但德语。如果你把我灌得大醉，
I can sing downtown in German. Really? Do we have any booze? Later. Wear some booze. Later. Later. All right. Next question. What's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? There's so many. I work mostly internationally these days. There's so many, would have to be Italy and I think I would say Portofino. Just beautiful blue, blue ocean water. Of course, incredible food. And just sort of this rare little village hanging on the side of a cliff. And I remember being there with my husband and we were just falling in love. It just seems so idyllic. I love to go back
我可以用德语唱《市区》（Downtown）。真的吗？我们有酒吗？等会儿。带点酒来。等会儿。等会儿。好吧。下一个问题。你去过并且绝对热爱的一个地方是哪里？有太多了。我这几年主要在国际上工作。有太多了，一定得是意大利，我想我会说是波托菲诺。那里的海水蓝得简直不可思议。当然，还有令人赞不绝口的美食。还有那种悬挂在悬崖边上的罕见小村庄。我记得我和丈夫在那里，我们正坠入爱河。它看起来是那么田园诗般。我很想在脑海中重回
there in my mind. Portofino, Italy, people. Question number four. What do you like to do on the weekend? I love to watch old movies. I've got four books going at once usually. And one of the nights, Friday, Saturday or Sunday, I just love to have a bunch of friends over and cook. That's my favorite, favorite thing. Love to cook. And I live part-time in LA and part-time on an island, on Orcas Island up in Washington State, which by the way I had turned Ken and Marissa onto. And so I see them all the time. They were at my son's wedding a year ago. We see each other all the time. That's wonderful.
那个地方。意大利的波托菲诺，各位。第四个问题。你喜欢在周末做什么？我喜欢看老电影。我通常同时在读四本书。其中一个晚上，周五、周六或周日，我特别喜欢邀请一帮朋友来家里做饭。那是我的最爱，最喜欢的事情。喜欢做饭。我有一半时间住在洛杉矶，一半时间住在岛上，在华盛顿州的奥卡斯岛，顺便说一句，这个地方还是我安利给肯和玛丽莎的。所以我经常见到他们。一年前他们还参加了我儿子的婚礼。我们经常见面。太棒了。
Can you imagine that I get to have Ken Quapus in my life forever now? So amazing. So yeah, cooking, most of the time on weekends, the joyous things are, you know, up there gathering a tribe. What is your go-to meal or what do you love to cook? What's your signature? I'm pretty famous for my garlic chicken. I take a chicken, I stuff it full of rosemary, and then I spread garlic all around the outside and then the inside. And the secret is malden sea salt flakes to kind of keep it juicy. You make a crust of salt.
你能想象我现在能让肯·夸普斯永远留在我的生命里吗？太神奇了。所以，是的，做饭，周末的大部分时间里，快乐的事情就是，你知道的，在那里聚集一群人。你的拿手菜是什么，或者你最喜欢做什么？你的招牌菜是什么？我的大蒜鸡相当出名。我拿一只鸡，里面塞满迷迭香，然后把大蒜铺在鸡的外面和里面。秘诀是马尔登海盐片，这样能保持肉质鲜嫩。你要用盐做成一个外壳。
That is a perennial. That's a perennial. Love to make that. I love it. I love that you're also kind of famous for it. You're known in circles. Some of my friends will literally call me up and said, you're not invited, but I really need your chicken.
那是一道常青菜。那是一道常青菜。非常喜欢做这个。我太喜欢了。我喜欢你也因此有点名气。你在圈子里很有名。我的一些朋友会直接打电话给我说，虽然没邀请你，但我真的很需要你的鸡。
Can you bring one over? Well, the last call sheet question is number five. What is your favorite midnight snack? Well, it's so wicked, of course, but it's ice cream. It's ice cream. And I've learned to like, I can't have it in the refrigerator. If I have it, it's gonna go.
你能带一只过来吗？好吧，最后一个通告单问题是第五个。你最喜欢的午夜小吃是什么？好吧，这当然太邪恶了，但它是冰淇淋。是冰淇淋。而且我学会了，像这样，我不能把它放在冰箱里。如果我有了它，它就保不住了。
It's gonna be the midnight snack and I'm gonna go eat the whole fricking tub. What's the flavor that does you in? Oh God, it's chocolate. It's almost flavor that does you in? Oh, God. It's almost always chocolate-oriented, but maybe with some caramel or some nuts, it's like, oh, it's my downfall. It's my downfall.
它就会变成深夜小吃，然后我会把整整一桶都吃光。是什么口味让你沦陷？噢，天哪，是巧克力。几乎是……是什么口味让你沦陷？噢，天哪。几乎总是以巧克力为主，但可能加了一点焦糖或坚果，这就好比，噢，这是我的软肋。这是我的软肋。
I guess we all have them. But I've learned, if I want to stay slender, which is like, that was years ago, what am I talking about? But no ice cream. Don't keep any ice cream in the refrigerator. Get it out. Make somebody else eat it. Aw, Denny, this was wonderful. Is there anything that we failed to ask you or that you would like
我想我们都有。但我明白了，如果我想保持苗条，这就好比，那是多年前的事了，我在说什么呢？但没有冰淇淋。不要在冰箱里放任何冰淇淋。把它拿走。让别人去吃吧。哦，丹妮，这太棒了。有什么是我们漏掉没问你的，或者你想在离开前分享的吗？
to share before we go? Oh my God. It was such a great talk. You guys made it so easy. I just want to say one moment that I love from Boys and Girls is when Jim comes back upstairs and he says, how did it go? And you said, we watched a video about our changing body. Yes. That's such a good joke. It was so classic. I think we covered everything, all our favorite moments.
哦，天哪。这是一次非常棒的交谈。你们把它变得太简单了。我只想说一个我非常喜欢的来自《男女之间》的时刻，那就是吉姆回到楼上时，他说，进展得怎么样？然后你说，我们看了一部关于我们身体变化的视频。是的。这个笑话太棒了。太经典了。我想我们涵盖了一切，我们所有最喜欢的时刻。
It was just joyous to walk down memory lane with you guys. Thank you. Thank you so much. Hmm. Well, a big thank you to Denny for joining us in the studio. And before we go, we did want to mention a couple of extra little scenes in the superfan episode that we just loved. So many fantastic tiny moments.
和你们一起回顾过去真是太快乐了。谢谢你们。非常感谢。嗯。好吧，非常感谢丹妮来到我们的录音室做客。在我们离开之前，我们确实想提一下我们超级粉丝剧集中几个特别喜欢的额外小片段。有太多精彩的小瞬间了。
There are such gems, like there's a whole Toby runner, because you know, he doesn't go down into the warehouse. So the camera kind of checks in on him throughout the day, and he's reading the paper, he's juggling. At one point, he's full on taking a nap. Like he's put chairs together and made a little bed. Yes. And there's a lot of extra stuff that happens both in the conference room with Jan,
这些都是宝藏，比如托比有一整条支线，因为你知道，他没有下到仓库。所以摄像机会在一天中不时切到他，他在看报纸，在玩杂耍。有一会儿，他简直是在打瞌睡。就像他把椅子拼在一起做成了一张小床。是的。而且有许多额外的事情发生，无论是在简的会议室里，
but also down in the warehouse. We talked a little bit about it with Denny. There's this great moment at the end where all the guys realize that they have been unloading a truck that was meant for delivery. Yes, it's so fun. And we also talked a little bit about our other favorite
还是在仓库里。我们和丹妮稍微聊了聊这个。最后有一个极棒的时刻，所有伙计们意识到他们一直在卸一辆原本用于配送的卡车。是的，太有趣了。我们还稍微聊了聊我们另一个最喜欢的
moment, which are these two tags at the very end of the episode with Lonnie and Madge. Yeah, so Lonnie is Saran wrapping a big group of boxes and the camera crew is filming him. And then that moment follows Madge pushing a cart. They cracked us up. Let's hear him. Why are you even filming this? I'm walking.
时刻，也就是剧集最后洛尼和玛奇的这两个彩蛋。是的，所以洛尼正在用保鲜膜包裹一大箱纸箱，摄像组在拍摄他。然后接下来的镜头是玛奇推着一辆推车。他们把我们逗乐了。让我们听听他们的声音。你们为什么还要拍这个？我在走路。
Let's see how interesting I can make this. How's that? Is that getting better? How about that one? I turn the corner. I pretend I'm a race car sometimes. How's that? Is that getting better? How about that one? I turn the corner. I pretend I'm a race car sometimes I gotta take a breath. What?
来看看我能把它弄得有多有趣。怎么样？这样有变好吗？那一个呢？我转过拐角。有时我假装自己是一辆赛车。怎么样？这样有变好吗？那一个呢？我转过拐角。有时我假装自己是一辆赛车。我得喘口气。什么？
Don't take me. I'm wanted in three states. She's wanted in three states. I mean, it's just great. When I see those moments, that is when I really super appreciate those bigger episodes because we had so many funny people on the show. And bits like that would get cut for time. So I love that there's a place for them to live. Well, thank you so much for everyone for listening. We love doing this podcast so much.
别拍我。我在三个州被通缉。她在三个州被通缉。我的意思是，这真是太棒了。当我看到那些时刻时，才是我真正超级感激那些更大体量剧集的时候，因为我们在剧中有很多搞笑的人。像这样的桥段会因为时间关系而被剪掉。所以我很高兴它们能有一个容身之所。好吧，非常感谢大家的收听。我们太喜欢做这个播客了。
And we're just so thankful for days like today. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil.
我们对像今天这样的日子感到非常感激。我们下周见。感谢收听 Office Ladies。《Office Ladies》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。Odyssey 的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和利亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《Office Ladies》由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。